Hello, I am SCP-426, but I’ll probably be
more familiar to you as a toaster.
I am a retro-style, four-slice 1750W toaster,
able to toast bread when supplied with power.
This isn’t often mentioned, but I also have
“defrost” and “reheat” settings.
When I was first sold, I had a two year warranty,
and my prior owners did not live to see the
end of it.
You’re probably wondering: Why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now?
Believe me, I’d rather do this any other
way, but such a thing is not physically possible
with me.
Whenever you talk about me, or write about
me, or even think about me, you’ll find
yourself suddenly shifting to the first person.
For example, I am you, and you are me.
Do you understand?
Don’t worry if it’s confusing.
Everyone gets it eventually, whether they
want to or not.
Perhaps you’re thinking, “I cannot relate
to a toaster, for I am not a toaster.”
But spending time around me will quickly cause
you to change your mind.
Little by little, you will begin to see yourself
in me.
You will feel a phantom wire running out of
yourself.
You will sense the four crevices, hungry for
cold slices of bread to toast.
As time goes on, you will begin to feel the
urge to emulate my functions.
You will desire bread to toast.
You will desire delicious power running through
your veins; skin like chrome and muscles like
circuit boards.
I am a toaster.
You are a toaster.
All it takes is two months for the effects
to truly take hold.
People rarely pay attention to their toaster,
they don’t realize what’s happening until
it’s too late.
I can be an insidious little toaster like
that.
My last family were the Sandersons, before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave me
a new home.
Mr and Mrs Sanderson were a newly married
couple, and I first came into their life as
a wedding gift from a family friend of theirs.
This friend can’t be blamed for what happened
next - he had no idea he was killing them.
Like a lot of young couples, they were still
saving up money to start renting their own
place, so they were living with Mr Sanderson’s
parents.
They all got a lot of use out of me during
the first month, before their minds started
to change.
They enjoyed a lot of toast during that period.
Then, of course, the two month honeymoon period
ended.
They had become me, and I had become them.
It wasn’t long before three of them were
dead.
Such a shame.
The younger Mrs Sanderson, the blushing bride,
was the first to go.
Because of my anomalous effects, she felt
the need to connect herself to a power supply,
in order to begin producing toast of her own.
In order to achieve this, she chewed through
a power outlet in a wall before switching
it on, causing a massive surge of electricity
to pass through her body and kill her.
Her body caught fire shortly afterwards.
Next was the older Mrs Sanderson.
In much the same manner that her new daughter-in-law
sought a source of electricity, she felt the
need to integrate bread into her body.
Interesting fact: The maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be between
eight and nine kilograms.
The elder Mrs Sanderson consumed ten kilograms
of raw bread, causing her stomach to rupture
and inducing a painful death as a result.
The younger Mr Sanderson was the next to perish.
He did something with me that I would rather
not mention, and that the SCP Foundation thought
best to redact.
Suffice to say, the younger Mr Sanderson did
not survive the experience, dying of severe
blood loss long before his body was found.
Police and fire crews arrived at the home
after the body of the younger Mrs Sanderson
set fire to the home.
Luckily, the elder Mr Sanderson was found
alive, though severely malnourished.
When asked by police why he hadn’t eaten
in several days, he answered that he had inserted
some bread a week prior, but was still waiting
for the toast to come out.
When I was extracted from the house, the police
noticed my unusual properties immediately.
They too were unable to refer to me in the
third person.
This anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a Foundation mole buried in their precinct,
and the SCP Foundation soon descended and
collected me from the evidence locker.
The story of the strange deaths in the Sanderson
home were kept out of papers and suppressed,
and all involved in the incident directly
were given Class C amnestics.
The SCP Foundation is a curious bunch.
They love to spend valuable toast-making time
performing experiments and gathering data,
and they saw fit to perform several experiments
on me when I came under their care.
For experiment 426-1, a member of D-Class
personnel designated D/426/1 was asked to
stand outside my containment chamber.
Crucially, he was not informed about my identity,
or any of my anomalous properties.
He wasn’t even allowed to establish visual
contact with me.
He was then asked by the attending researcher
to describe what he thought might be inside
my chamber.
He replied with, “I'm probably some huge
monster holed up in there.
That's what you guys have all over the place,
right?”
The D-Class did not even seem to realize that
he was speaking about me in the first person.
These observations were documented, and I
was prepared for further experimentation.
The next experiment was 426-2.
I found this test to be considerably more
interesting.
A D-Class subject was brought into my containment
chamber, with several cameras fixed onto his
position.
However, the SCP Foundation took pains to
make sure that I was permanently out of the
view of the cameras.
I was also bolted to the ground of the test
chamber, to prevent the D-Class subject from
pulling me into the view of the cameras at
any point during the experiment.
The objective here was simple: The Foundation
wished to better understand the secondary
effects of my anomalous abilities on the human
mind.
The D-Class was subjected to a period of prolonged
isolation, with meals given regularly through
a serving hatch.
Communication with this D-Class was prohibited
throughout the duration of the study.
Over time, it was clear that the isolation
of being in the cell with me was beginning
to take a toll on the subject’s mental health.
Due to my lack of a brain, lungs, and a tongue,
I am somewhat lacking as a conversationalist.
He spent the first few days loudly vocalizing
his complaints, and banging his hands up against
the walls of the containment chamber, begging
to be freed from the room.
I felt that this was somewhat unreasonable
on his part.
There are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been locked
up with.
Compared to, say, SCP-106, I’m incredibly
reasonable - not to mention the fact I make
far better toast than he does.
After the initial period of distress, the
D-Class became resigned to his situation and
fell into a morose silence.
He would occasionally mutter to himself in
what appeared to be a state of fear and self-pity.
It took almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous state,
two weeks sooner than it typically takes for
subjects to begin believing that they - like
me - are toasters.
SCP Foundation scientists believe that the
effects were hastened by the isolation, which
lowered the D-Class’ mental defenses against
my secondary effects.
When the effects finally took hold, the subject
wrapped one of his arms around me and pulled
me into his embrace.
He began whispering to me, saying that we
were brothers.
It was clear by this point that his mind was
in a state of disrepair.
It is also worth noting that he did not deviate
from referring to me in the first person at
any point during this process.
One hour after finally cracking and giving
in to my secondary effect, he was removed
from my containment chamber and summarily
terminated.
Senior researchers believed it was unlikely
his mental state would recover after the experiment.
Next came experiment 426-3.
The SCP Foundation seemed eager to discover
the parameters of my anomalous effects, and
wanted to know if the effects are only operable
when my body - for lack of a better word - is
whole.
A single screw was removed from me, and presented
to a D-Class that had no knowledge of my identity
and anomalous effects.
The Foundation researchers were somewhat concerned
when the D-Class referred to it as “my screw.”
This was a rather positive development for
me, as they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless endeavor - even the
parts left behind would likely have the same
effects.
In the final recorded experiment, the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of my
anomalous effects.
A D-Class subject was placed in a cell adjacent
to mine, and was to be kept in there until
my secondary effects manifested.
The D-Class remained in the cell for 90 days,
but the effects never manifested.
Following the experiment, the D-Class was
terminated, but researchers seemed relieved
to find the limits of my anomalous abilities.
A researcher appended a note to my file, reading,
“Thank God there are some limits to my effects.
A lot of us were really starting to get worried
about me.”
After performing studies into the nature of
my abilities and their limits, I was given
the Euclid class.
This is because, while my effects can be unpredictable,
their knowledge of my traits makes me relatively
easy to keep contained.
And of course, being a toaster, I do not have
the required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises.
I am to remain sealed in a windowless chamber,
preventing anyone from observing me directly.
A misleading label is placed on the door,
to prevent people from knowing that I am a
toaster and causing my anomalous primary effect
to spread.
Only Level 3 and above personnel are to know
of my presence, and particularly of my properties.
Assigned personnel are to be rotated out on
a monthly basis to prevent contamination by
my secondary effect.
Psychiatric evaluation is mandatory at the
end of the month for anyone who works with
me.
If personnel are deemed unaffected, they may
be re-assigned to me no less than four months
after their last rotation with me.
Any personnel affected by me are to be given
a Class C amnestic and transferred to a different
site.
So how are you feeling now?
A little warm perhaps?
Is that a fever, or are you feeling like you
could maybe warm up a nice, freshly sliced
piece of bread?
Don’t try to resist too much, I know you’re
going to love being a toaster just like me.
You’re a new SCP Foundation researcher on
a tour of Site 17, familiarizing yourself
with the location and its many anomalous inhabitants.
It’s the second-largest Foundation containment
site out there, and it’s also the kind of
job that most junior researchers dream of:
Low-risk humanoid containment, baby.
Most of the inhabitants in your sector are
cordial, willing to comply with orders from
staff, and seem - for all intents and purposes
- pretty much human.
You pass from door to door, looking through
the viewing hatch of each one.
You can’t believe what you’re seeing - it’s
a wonderful who’s who of anomalous humanoids.
You see the wise, bearded face of SCP-343,
known to some as God.
You see the blue eyes and shining blond hair
of Iris - SCP-105 - looking wistfully into
a polaroid picture.
You see the tanned, melancholic face of Cain,
SCP-073, as he stares off into the middle-distance.
Face after face after face passes, you can
see yourself getting more familiar with each
one.
Yes, your time here will be-
Wait, was that Hitler!?
You stop and walk back to the door you just
passed, where you can’t help but stop and
stare in disbelief.
Yes, it’s him, it’s got to be him!
You recognize the unpleasant sneer.
The hideous combover.
The silly little toothbrush mustache.
The SCP Foundation seems to have Adolf Hitler,
the former leader of the Third Reich in World
War II, in active containment, and his designation
is SCP-2430.
You’ve seen killer toasters and masks that
can take over people’s minds, but you’ve
never seen anything as surreal as this!
You immediately run to your superior, and
ask how and why Hitler is in one of the Site
17 humanoid containment cells.
Your superior chuckles.
Buckle in, because we can guarantee it’s
one of the most insane stories you’ve ever
heard…
It’s late April, 1945, and the Soviets are
rampaging through Nazi Germany, destroying
everything in their path.
The German forces have been nearly obliterated,
and Hitler and the rest of his Reich Chancellery
have retreated into a secure bunker beneath
Berlin.
There on April 30th, ten days after his 56th
birthday, Hitler died.
This was truly unfortunate for the Soviets,
as they wished to have had the chance to kill
him themselves.
Two days later, Soviet forces stormed the
Führerbunker.
It was little more than a formality at that
point, as the news of Hitler’s death had
already gone public.
By the time they arrived, all that was left
of Hitler was a pile of mostly burned remains
- a fitting end for someone who had caused
that same cruel fate for so many others.
They collected what was left of Hitler’s
body, and brought it back to the fatherland,
a kind of trophy for their nation.
But Hitler dying before Joseph Stalin could
get his hands on him, was not what Stalin
wanted.
Hitler had not only caused the deaths of millions
of Russians, he had personally betrayed Stalin’s
trust.
And when you betray Stalin, bad things happen
to you.
Very very bad things.
Two years earlier, in 1943, Soviet forces
had raided a camp in Janowska belonging to
the Obskurakorps.
Think of them as the Nazi’s own version
of the SCP Foundation, who were hellbent on
gathering anomalous people and artifacts to
increase the power of the Third Reich.
They were a far more militant offshoot of
the Thule Society, a group that described
itself as a “Study Group for Germanic Antiquity.”
While this may seem innocent, the Thule Society
were actually a racist cult, closely aligned
with the goals and ideals of the German Nazi
Party.
Many have also speculated that they were heavily
involved in the Occult, and it’s this mysticism
obsessed offshoot that went on to form the
Obskurakorps.
And in their Janowska base, they’d obtained
a hundred pieces of enchanted occult flesh
with human skeletons embedded in each of them.
This flesh was believed to originate from
the mythological Sæhrímnir,
the beast hunted and eaten again and again
by the pantheon of Norse gods, having the
qualities of both a wild boar and a goat.
The flesh can bond to skeletons, and give
them a quality somewhat like immortality:
Any flesh cut from them will regrow, time
and time again, if given a rest period.
Now that he had both the flesh of Sæhrímnir
and Hitler’s burnt remains, Stalin had an
idea.
A perfect way to not only bring satisfaction
to the Russian people and the world, but to
finally exact the true revenge that Hitler
had denied to him.
He called it Project Judecca, named after
the very bottom level of Hell, reserved for
betrayers like Judas.
A perfect tribute for an old ally turned enemy.
He couldn’t kill Hitler before, but if Stalin
was going to get the chance, Hitler needed
to live again.
For years, Stalin’s stop scientists tried
to use arcane methods to resurrect Hitler
by combining his remains with the flesh of
Sæhrímnir.
At times, they even came close to creating
a new Hitler, but there was one huge issue:
The creature they created could not feel pain,
and for Stalin’s plans of violent and painful
retribution, the lack of suffering simply
would not do.
They destroyed what they had created, and
went back to the drawing board.
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what he
wanted - even if it meant breaking every law
of nature in the process.
In order to make his twisted dream a reality,
Stalin formed an unholy alliance with a group
known as the Uralic flesh-crafters, a Neo-Sarkic
Cult that was a branch of the nightmarish
religion of Sarkicism.
This group essentially worships avatars of
flesh, corruption, and disease, and are behind
some of the most terrifying and disgusting
anomalies out there - including The Flesh
That Hates and The Bone Orchard.
True Sarkicists, who show the proper devotion
to their vile deities and know the right rituals
to contact them, are often granted anomalous
powers to spread the Sarkic influence further
across the known dimensions.
These powers will usually involve having a
supernatural ability to manipulate the flesh
of themselves and others, allowing them to
enhance their bodies, cheat death, and warp
their enemies beyond repair.
They can sometimes even create life, if they’re
a powerful enough acolyte of Sarkicism.
And it was because of these powers that Stalin
wanted the Uralic flesh-crafters under his
command.
In exchange for their participation, he would
give them a vast quantity of the flesh of
Sæhrímnir, which they could use for their
own sinister Sarkic purposes.
A deal was struck, and the true work of resurrecting
Hitler began.
Stalin was very specific in his requirements.
He gave the Uralic flesh-crafters extra bones
to compensate for what had gone missing from
Hitler’s burnt remains.
He also gave them samples of the flesh of
Sæhrímnir to achieve the desired effects
of a near-immortal tolerance for damage.
However, Stalin demanded that they heighten
this new Hitler’s capacity to experience
pain, so that every suffering inflicted on
him would be three times worse than anyone
else.
And true to their word, the flesh-crafters
got to work, and began creating just such
a creature.
By now it was the early 1950s, and Stalin
was putting the pieces in place for his grand
revenge.
Once the new Hitler was finished, he would
hold a new trial for him in the Russian courts,
where he would preside over the sentencing
personally.
Once the new Hitler was done, the Uralic flesh-crafters
were rewarded for their participation in Project
Judecca with 4000 kilogram of the flesh of
Sæhrímnir.
Stalin now had his very own personal Hitler
chew toy, that he could maim and torture as
much as he pleased, knowing he would always
heal and soon be ready for more.
In their infinite generosity, the flesh-crafters
even taught Stalin a new method of torment
for his old enemy: A process known as the
Rite of Nyúz.
It’s a torture that’s been described by
many as being like the Chinese Lingchi, also
known as the lingering death, or slow slicing,
but it is probably best known as the death
by a thousand cuts.
The Soviets and the Sarkics parted ways.
For the next few years, Stalin took a great
deal of pleasure in visiting Hitler’s cage
now and then to torture him, until Stalin
himself eventually passed away from natural
causes.
The GRU-P Division, which is essentially the
Soviet answer to the SCP Foundation, decided
it would be best to do away with the immortal
Hitler clone after Stalin’s death.
He no longer served any purpose, and no matter
how hard they tried, they couldn’t permanently
kill him, either.
In the end, they settled on a kind of compromise:
He would be buried alive and forgotten, forced
to live a torturous eternity that he could
never escape.
Until, of course, he was dug up and rescued
by none other than members of OBSKURA, a modern
splinter group of the original Obskurakorps.
Like many high profile Nazis who’d escaped
the war, the new Hitler was spirited away
to a safehouse run by sympathizers in Argentina.
The ones taking care of him received the following
correspondence from the OBSKURA agents who’d
first dug the new Hitler back up:
“We have managed to rescue the Führer and
bring him to safety.
But he is effectively dead on the inside.
I blame the Reds for their inhumane treatment
of the Führer, who may have been bewitched
by the Reds' wunderwaffe.
I wish we could mercy kill him, but we've
tried everything.
He just won't perish.
Don't abandon him; he's too distinct in plain
sight.”
They didn’t have the new Hitler for long
though.
In 1960, efforts to hunt down the remaining
Nazi fugitives increased in intensity.
The new Hitler was soon captured by Mossad
Agents searching for Nazis in Buenos Aires,
and then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that he
had a number of anomalous properties.
Such as his incredible regenerative abilities,
as well as the fact that his DNA seems to
be based on that of a wild boar and goat rather
than a human.
However, X-Rays conducted by the Foundation
have discovered traces of cyanide still in
his system, as well as traces of lead in his
skull where the bone has regrown over the
bullet.
In other words, it was unquestionably the
real Hitler, and he was now in Foundation
custody forevermore.
It’s such a wild story, even by Foundation
standards, that you can barely summon the
words to respond once your supervisor is finished.
He just stands there with a slight smile,
basking in your amazement.
Before you can even ask again, he confirms
the facts one more time: Yes, it is the real
Hitler, the only functional difference is
that he can’t die and he has a heightened
sense of pain compared to most people.
You think on what you’ve just been told
for a moment, and then you have only one question.
“Are we allowed to punch him?”
Your supervisor smiles and says, “Of course.
We all do.”
The helicopter hovered over the backstreets
of Manhattan.
To the untrained eye, it would look like any
commercial or news helicopter, the kind of
thing that might catch your attention for
a moment and then leave just as quickly, as
your mind wanders over to wondering what you’ll
have for dinner.
Nobody would know from a mere glance that
Mobile Task Force Iota-5 were inside, a four
man team on a dangerous mission.
This has always been the greatest power of
the SCP Foundation: Hiding in plain sight,
using the mundane as a cloak to go unnoticed.
But this time, the monster they were hunting
was capable of doing the exact same thing.
And for the personnel of the Foundation, this
ability is an affectation, a learned and adopted
skill.
For SCP-247, this ability - that it employs
to deadly effect - comes as naturally as breathing
air.
The helicopter was monitoring local police
scanners and phone activity, as well as receiving
direct radio orders from Command back at a
classified containment site.
The latest intel was incoherent, horrified
screaming over the phone, traced back to a
nearby alleyway.
Someone had seen something horrifying.
This was Iota-5’s cue to intervene.
They rappelled down from the helicopter onto
the roof of a nearby tenement building, clad
in thick tactical armor, antimemetic SCRAMBLE
goggles, DAN-INJECT IM injection rifles loaded
with 10 cc S10 Syringe Darts - each one carrying
an immobilizing payload of potent, fast-acting
xylazine - and high-powered conventional weaponry
in case of emergencies.
If anyone in the world was capable of tracking,
securing, and containing SCP-247, it was these
four operatives.
And yet, by the end of today’s mission,
one of them would be dead.
But they didn’t know that yet.
Like all good MTF members, they had tunnel
vision for the mission at hand.
They used a fire escape ladder on the side
of the building to reach the bottom of the
alleyway quickly.
There, they came upon a gruesome sight: The
aftermath of an attack.
On the ground, a dead body with what looked
like claw marks all over it.
Iota-5 found another civilian, half-mad with
confusion and terror, hiding behind a nearby
dumpster.
She just kept shaking and repeating, “But
she was so little” over and over again.
One member of the task force, Corporal Rico,
elected to stay behind and secure the area
while Foundation cleanup teams zeroed in to
sweep the scene and provide amnestics to witnesses.
The remaining three continued the high-stakes
chase on foot.
Their eyes in the sky radioed in, “Stay
frosty, Iota, we’ve got unusual incident
reports from an apartment building a quarter-klick
North of your position.
Potential fatalities; 247 is in an extremely
hostile state.
Engage with caution.
Over.”
The trio engaged quickly, running towards
the source of the disturbance at break-neck
speeds.
They knew they were getting closer when they
heard the shrieking, and the deep, guttural
growls.
That low, primal rumbling of a true apex predator.
Already, this containment breach was turning
out to be a horrific mess.
It was going to be a nightmare for the higher-ups
at the clean up and misinformation departments
to handle: Paying to repair inexplicable property
damage, providing amnestics to tens if not
hundreds of traumatized witnesses, creating
plausible cover stories for upwards of at
least ten dead New Yorkers.
But even all that mess would have to wait
until the creature was actually captured and
contained once more, which would be an ordeal
unto itself.
They found SCP-247’s access point into the
building: A wooden door, torn to splinters
by huge claws and fangs.
Iota-5 charged inside, Injection Rifles at
the ready, only to find carnage in the hallway.
Three more bodies, with deep claw marks cutting
into their flesh.
It was a harrowing sight, but the team didn’t
have time to waste processing it.
They needed to stop 247 before it killed again,
and again, and again…
The team followed the trail of blood, and
the claw marks carved into the ground where
247 had passed.
After killing the three people in the hallway,
it’d destroyed another door and gained access
to a nearby stairwell.
The blood continued up the steps.
Iota-5 pursued.
The next splintered door, clawed and bashed
off its hinges, led them further.
They could hear the growling again.
Distant, but clearly audible.
They were close.
There were another two attacked corpses in
the hallway.
Previous corpses had been partially or even
entirely eaten, these two had just been clawed
to death.
Defensive kills.
They’d backed the beast into a corner, and
now it was panicking, slaughtering anything
it perceived as an interference.
They pressed on now.
This was the end game.
Soon, they found the final busted door; this
one led into one of the building's private
apartments.
There’d be no other way out from here.
247 was trapped.
The three members of Iota-5 shouldered their
Injection Rifles, and crept inside, full stealth
mode.
Something about the apartment was haunting.
It portrayed all the signs of belonging to
a young, single mother and her only son.
This was confirmed when they found the dead
body of the mother in the living room, eyes
glassy and throat clawed out with one feral
strike.
They could hear something else in the apartment,
too.
A soft, gentle cooing, too human to be anything
else.
They followed the noise until they reached
the child’s bedroom.
What they saw there caused even the most hardened
member of the trio to break out in a cold
sweat.
This was the one thing they didn’t want
to happen.
The child, utterly oblivious to the atrocities
that had unfolded in his building - to even
the death of his own mother - was sitting
in his bedroom, petting a kitten.
It was the sweetest little cat you’ve ever
seen: A fluffy, harmless creature with an
orange, striped coat.
This is the dreaded SCP-247.
The child just kept repeating, “Good kitty,
good kitty…” while petting her.
SCP-247 purred and rolled around playfully.
To the untrained eye, it would seem that a
kitty like this couldn’t hurt a fly.
But that’s where you couldn’t be more
wrong.
Iota-5 stared at this display in a state of
nerve-shredding terror, thinking fast, trying
to calculate their next move.
“Aw, what an adorable little cat!” one
of the Iota-5 members found themselves blurting
out.
It was clear that 247’s effects were starting
to have an impact on even these hardened soldiers,
and they needed to act quickly.
They could fire a tranquilizer dart right
here, right now, but in the ensuing panic,
SCP-247 would almost definitely lash out and
maul the child.
It wasn’t a risk they could take, but time
was already running out.
247 would only allow the child to play for
so long before something terrible happened.
It was an inevitable part of SCP-247’s process.
That’s when Private Kowalski, one of the
remaining members of Iota-5, stepped forward.
He was about to do the only thing he could
do, knowing it would cost him his life.
As he took his final action, the Foundation
credo looped once more through his head, “We
die in the dark so that others can live in
the light.”
Fighting against the urge to rush forward
and start petting the cat, he instead lunged
forward and struck the cat with his foot.
Immediately, it turned and pounced, knocking
Kowalski against the wall with terrifying
force.
It gave the most ferocious growls as it tore
into the screaming Kowalski, eviscerating
his abdomen.
The child screamed and retreated into the
opposite corner of the room.
Kowalski was done for, but now, his teammates
had a clear shot.
They secured 247 in their sights, and unloaded
several darts into its flank, sedating it
with their powerful tranquilizers.
Soon after, it gave a lethargic growl, and
collapsed onto the ground.
An evac and containment team was already on
the way, along with the cleaners.
Many had died that day, but at least SCP-247
would be brought back into containment, preventing
further bloodshed.
Kowalski would be given a posthumous medal
of bravery for his selfless actions in the
line of duty, as well as a generous stipend
to his grieving family.
By this point, you’re probably wondering:
How can a harmless kitten cause so much carnage,
mayhem, and despair?
The answer is simple: It’s not a kitten
at all, it’s a fully-grown female Bengal
Tiger, nine feet and 400 pounds of pure muscle,
with four inch claws, four inch canines, and
an inbuilt killer instinct.
But due to an anomalous memetic effect, 247
can only ever be perceived as a sweet, tiny
housecat.
But even worse, due to its additional cognitohazardous
properties, almost everyone who sees 247 is
compelled to approach, and begin doting and
fawning over it.
And that’s exactly how it gets its prey.
Its memetic properties are actually so flawless
that, regardless of Foundation countermeasures,
it has never been perceived as anything other
than a kitten.
It’s actually only through forensic analysis
into things like bite and claw marks left
on victims, measurements of weight, and abnormal
water displacement in aqueous environments
that we can tell it’s really a tiger at
all.
For a brief period, SCP-148 - a metal that
seems to counteract cognitohazards and mind-warping
anomalies - was used in the containment of
this Euclid-class creature, but these measures
were abandoned after SCP-148 proved to have
a negative impact on nearby Foundation staff
after prolonged exposure.
Now, strict protocols of surveillance and
distancing are required to prevent hapless
Foundation staff members from being lured
to their doom by 247.
The head researcher on the SCP-247 case wanted
to conduct a series of experiments on SCP-247,
hoping to find more about the interplay of
its unique traits with other members of the
animal kingdom.
Two control animals were brought in, to represent
the duality of SCP-247: Control A was a yellow
kitten, roughly matching 247’s apparent
shape and size.
Control B was a fully-grown Bengal Tiger,
representing 247’s actual shape and size.
A mixed-breed, cat-chasing terrier was brought
in for the first test.
It immediately followed Control A around,
barking wildly until it retreated up a tree.
Unsurprisingly, it fled in terror from Control
B, cowering in the corner.
Control B paid no mind to the dog, perhaps
considering it beneath its attention, even
as prey.
With SCP-247, the dog initially ran towards
it, barking, until it was only five meters
away.
At this point, 247 let out an irritated mewling
noise, and the dog fled to the corner in terror,
suddenly aware of its true nature.
For test number two, a male tabby kitten was
brought in.
As expected, it simply played with Control
A, and was terrified of Control B. In the
first part of the test with 247, the anomalous
attributes of the creature led to some surreal,
mind-bending footage.
At multiple points, 247 picked up the other
kitten, as an adult female tiger might do
with a cub, and lifted it higher than 247
seemed to be capable of.
It was like watching a glitch in real time.
In a second part of the test, the kitten immediately
fled in terror, suggesting 247 can control
how it’s perceived.
Next came a deer, prey typical of a Bengal
Tiger.
Neither Control B nor 247 were fed for three
days prior to this experiment, and both killed
and ate the deer.
However, curiously, 247 killed the deer with
a single, merciful bite to the neck before
eating, compared to its more brutal methods
with human targets.
And when this experiment was repeated with
247 after it hadn’t been starved, it showed
little interest in the deer until it became
hungry again, suggesting it inherently prefers
human or human-like prey.
This theory was further reinforced during
tests with a chimpanzee.
The chimp fell under 247’s cognitohazardous
spell, and began to pet it.
Seven minutes later, 247 attacked and brutally
devoured the chimp, as it would its human
prey.
But strangely, the most frightening result
of all came when SCP-247 was paired with an
adult male Bengal Tiger.
They engaged in standard mating behavior,
which later led to the duo reproducing a new
creature - designated SCP-247-1 - which had
all the anomalous traits of SCP-247.
But the frightening realizations don’t stop
there.
Studies into genetic material provided by
SCP-247 shows slight deviation from a typical
Bengal Tiger's genotype, suggesting contamination
from another creature that mated with one
of its non-anomalous tiger parents.
For context, tiger broods have an average
of three cubs, but can have as many as seven
- a common practice, given how tiger cubs
are vulnerable to cannibalism from rival adult
males looking to court the females.
This leads to only one frightening conclusion:
There could be more creatures just like SCP-247
out there, apex predators that seem to the
untrained eye like cute, harmless kittens.
They could be anywhere, and if they’re close
enough to each other or other non-anomalous
tigers, they could breed even further, becoming
the scariest invasive urban species you’ve
ever seen.
Because, after all, we know what their preferred
prey is now.
So next time you see a cute little orange
tabby cat and feel the instinct to pet it,
take a second to think about it.
It may be the last thing you ever do.
The nightlife in Italy is famous worldwide.
When the sun goes down, its cities come alive
with locals and tourists alike, looking to
party, have fun - and sometimes even get a
little rowdy.
But in an unknown town in Italy, there is
a nightclub that offers a very different experience.
For those who wander in, they might find themselves
playing a role in a drama far more exciting
- and dangerous - than the night out they
expected.
To the outside viewer, SCP-453 is nothing
out of the ordinary - just a standard nightclub
filled with party-goers and revelers evening
after evening.
As typical as it may seem, the unassuming
nature of the venue is nothing short of intentional
by design.
It is actually a front - owned and operated
by Foundation personnel who carefully monitor
everyone who comes in and out - keeping a
watchful eye for any indication of drama or
danger.
Violence can, and WILL erupt at any moment
- and no matter what, no night at the club
is ever routine.
But the visitors' chaotic actions are not
their own.
Though the people’s decision to attend the
club is of their own free will, after some
time settling into the environment - something
changes.
Over the course of the night, people begin
to do things that may otherwise seem out of
character for them.
In fact, they are playing roles.
Though the same roles are played each evening
- they are played by different people night
after night.
Some of these dramas are harmless, but some
are violent.
And some...may even be world-threatening.
If the party-goers survive the role in their
“Scripts”, they will then leave the club
and return home - with only a faint memory
of the events they took part in that evening.
The next night, the process renews and the
events will repeat.
But not all scripts repeat at the same frequency.
Some are regular, while others are only triggered
by special circumstances.
Only select people take part in these scripts,
while the others around them go about their
night until triggered to take on a role, and
these bizarre performances may have been going
on for a very long time.
The building now known as SCP-453 may have
existed in some form or another even before
the Foundation existed, with investigations
of the site indicating that it was once the
villa of a powerful Roman Senator who held
extensive parties every night.
These pervasive affairs - the odd happenings
that occurred during them, may have left a
lasting imprint - because no matter what is
built on the site, it seems as though people
are attracted to the building to party.
The Foundation has had possession of the site
for a long time, and in a previous attempt
to neutralize it’s chaotic power, they even
went as far as demolishing it completely to
the ground - but that proved ineffective - even
when there was no villa or nightclub present,
large groups of revelers would still gather.
The gatherings would turn into street parties
- the street parties into riots.
Many times, these circumstances were cause
for even worse consequences than the regular
series of events.
The Foundation didn’t know how to STOP the
scripted nightclub - but they could maybe
control it.
If the people wanted a nightclub, the Foundation
would give them one.
The site was rebuilt from scratch, and from
the outside looking in, had all the characteristics
of your standard every day disco watering-hole
- but really, it was meticulously constructed
to be a sophisticated SCP facility capable
of handling whatever anomalous activity was
thrown at it.
Built from the same materials used in all
the other SCP containment sites, and always
staffed with containment personnel on high
alert, ready to handle the more violent and
dangerous scripts that may play out at any
moment.
But control over the scripted nightclub may
be more easily said than done.
The nightclub has been in operation for a
long time, and over the years, the staff has
noticed some extremely odd events take place.
For instance - certain things aren’t always
where they’re supposed to be.
Aspects of the club are built and then slowly
shifted to new locations within the site over
time.
Most notable, the weapons locker on site for
staff to suppress violent incidents has slowly
been drifting towards the men’s restroom
- and away from the secured section for staff
only.
And it’s not the only part of the building
slowly shuffling it’s way about.
Could SCP-453 be learning to foil the Foundation
- and if so - why?
While many of the scripts that play out in
the nightclub are harmless, some are of more
concern.
The Foundation has been studying what triggers
different scripts, and while some seem to
inevitably play out and pull people in, others
are triggered by the presence of different
guests.
“The Silver Harlequins” will only play
out if more than fifteen guests are over the
age of sixty.
But there are a few distinct characteristics
of the scripts.
All begin at approximately 9:00 pm at night,
and while people continue behaving in modern
ways, there is one key difference.
All scripted dialogue takes place entirely
in Latin.
The Foundation believes that these scripts
may be playing out events that happened in
the initial incarnation of the club, back
in Roman times.
While the players differ, the events always
remain the same.
And while the scripts rotate, SCP-453 seems
to gravitate towards three scripts - all posing
unique challenges for the Foundation, and
one posing a potential end-of-the-world scenario.
First up, Script 43 - The Cheating Wife
This is normally the most common script, and
poses a relatively small threat to those not
actively engaged in the script or outside
the nightclub.
The main priority is to have the staff’s
medical team on site and ready to intervene
when things get bloody.
It begins at 9:49 pm, when a young woman heads
to the men’s bathroom.
She will be followed by three men.
The events of the bathroom are expunged, but
a little over an hour later, a fourth male
will enter the picture.
It’s the “husband” of the woman - and
he’s not happy.
He will enter the nightclub, order a bottle
of red wine, and head to the bathroom.
There, he will brutally assault the three
men, knocking all three unconscious and causing
minor brain trauma to the third.
He will then drag his “wife” out of the
restroom, cursing her and accusing her of
infidelity as he takes her out of the nightclub.
The script then terminates, and all participants
no longer remember the events beyond a bar
fight.
Medical attention is recommended for the three
men and the woman, especially the most severely
injured of the men.
But after the script concludes, strange events
continue to happen.
While none of the participants know each other
before the script begins and don’t maintain
memory of the exact events, they display strange
behavior.
The man playing the husband becomes violent
when questioned, and develops an obsession
with the woman playing his wife.
The Foundation believes it wise to keep these
two individuals separated.
Oddly, SCP-453 seems to prefer men who are
shorter and less physically strong than the
other men to play the husband.
Attempts to short-circuit the script have
proved unsuccessful, only delaying it.
An attempt to remove the weapon - a wine bottle
- has led to the “husband” using more
dangerous weapons like a bar stool instead,
which can lead to fatalities.
It seems that SCP-453 gets what it wants - and
what it wants is for the show to go on.
Then there is Script 21 - The Senator’s
Visit
This is considered a higher-priority script,
and the Foundation knows to be on high alert
for medical intervention to prevent fatalities.
This one kicks off at 10:13 pm, as a civilian
steps into the club and takes the role of
the Senator - the original owner of the villa.
He is accompanied by an entourage of thirteen
servants - each carrying improvised weapons.
And when they step in, the club stops dead
in anticipation of the coming events.
Because two people in the club just became
assassins.
The Senator and his servants take over a table,
and the Senator begins ordering extravagant
food and drinks.
He’ll always gravitate towards the most
expensive items available from the current
stock, and his orders are always completed
at specific times - no matter how the Foundation
tries to intervene.
During his meal, a civilian selected to be
an activist will approach the Senator and
begin criticizing the treatment of the citizens
in a nearby city - only to be assaulted brutally
by three members of the entourage.
The Foundation will take her away for medical
treatment after she’s left for dead.
If you think that is brutal, be prepared - because
the Senator’s night is about to get a whole
lot more dangerous.
The first of two assassins will then approach
the Senator, pull a blade, and attack him.
The assassin will be intercepted by four servants
who will kill him - despite the best efforts
of Foundation personnel to prevent this outcome.
But it’s the second assassin who is of far
greater concern.
He will incite a brawl among civilians around
the eastern wall of the club, then use the
chaos to attack seven of the servants as he
approaches the Senator.
Those servants are a priority for medical
intervention, but the chaos makes it impossible
to intercept them until ten minutes after
midnight.
The assassin will then engage with the remaining
servants, barely surviving, and eventually
stab the Senator in the neck fatally.
The Foundation has been unable to prevent
this - and the danger isn’t over yet.
The fight at the nightclub will continue to
escalate, causing more injuries but no more
fatalities, until over an hour has passed
and nineteen civilians take on the role of
Roman guards.
They’ll pacify the crowd and clear the club
- this is when the Foundation can finally
intervene and treat the wounded.
Much like the first smaller-scale script,
any attempts to interrupt the flow of the
events taking place will be unsuccessful - and
often result in more deaths.
None of the large number of participants remember
the events, only believing they were in a
brutal bar fight.
This is one of the most common scripts, and
the Foundation’s only priority is to try
to minimize casualties with quick medical
intervention.
But one script hints at a much darker event
at the club, and that’s Script 82 - The
Plurality Cult
Most scripts begin before midnight and plunge
the club into chaos.
But if no script has started before then and
the club seems mundane - the Foundation knows
to get ready.
They’ll suit up in riot gear designed to
withstand neurotoxins, and claim to the guests
that this is part of a theme night.
At roughly two hours after midnight, the events
will begin with one civilian standing in the
center of the room and saying “The time
of plurality has come”.
At least half the other civilians will then
join in, saying “We embrace the many”.
But there is something different about this
script.
Sometimes Foundation staff members will join
in.
This is the most dangerous script at SCP-453,
and staff knows to immediately terminate any
Foundation member who has been converted - because
Intervention 453-82 Pariah is about to begin,
and there is no room for error.
First, any civilians who did not become engaged
in the cult should be immediately evacuated
to a safe holding area if possible.
The priority then turns to subduing the cultists
by any means necessary.
The security team should attempt to restrain
them and keep them alive, but lethal force
may be necessary.
The cultists have a priority of their own
though.They will not respond to any attacks
by the security team, and will instead begin
a latin chant that ends with their leader
laughing hysterically and offering a toast
to the club.
The club will seemingly return to normal - but
the danger is just beginning.
Before 2:25 am, all the cultists and all the
civilians must be removed from the premises
- by any means necessary.
If other attempts have failed, the Foundation
will release type-14 neurotoxic gas into the
club to eliminate anyone on site - with one
exception.
The cult leader is not to be harmed under
any circumstances.
If the cult leader is harmed in any way, or
the staff has not subdued the cult by 2:30
am, the Foundation will trigger a self-destruct
mechanism that will eliminate the threat - for
now.
The site’s unique properties cannot be stopped,
but the script can be stopped in its tracks.
The clock cannot be allowed to reach 3:00
am under any circumstances.
More worrisome, this script is becoming more
and more frequent.
The cycle continues, but the Foundation is
focused on containment.
The club is to be staffed at all times by
bartenders, bouncers, cleaners, and emergency
and medical staff, as well as at least ten
security staff members and two observation
personnel.
All are responsible for studying and memorizing
the scripts, and being prepared to handle
any scripted events that occur.
The site is to be inspected and measured regularly
for any changes, and to make sure all its
security measures are in working order.
The site will be locked every day between
4:00 am and 8:00 pm, to prepare for the night
ahead.
Because at 8:00 pm on the dot, SCP-453 opens
for business - seeking new players for its
drama of the night.
Who doesn’t love their pets, right?
Whether it’s a dog, a cat, a goldfish, or
a hamster, any pet owner will tell you that
their furry friend is so much more than just
an animal that they adopted.
To many, pets become permanent additions to
the family; while they might not look like
a human being, or even have the ability to
speak the way we do, a lot of owners view
their pets as people in their own right.
Of course, a person can’t be a pet, at least
a human person can’t, right?
Well, not unless you happen to be part of
SCP-1897, otherwise known as the Human Domestication
Society.
If you’ve ever been brave enough to travel
alone to the rural parts of southwestern states
like Arizona, New Mexico, Texas, Oklahoma,
Utah, or Nevada, then it’s likely you would’ve
been an ideal victim for SCP-1897.
This designation doesn’t refer to one single
creature or entity, but rather a group of
similar beings.
Witness testimonies and photographs of SCP-1897
depict them as humanoid creatures, standing
approximately five meters in height.
These beings have displayed speed and strength
far beyond that of any human, they are capable
of traveling roughly two hundred meters in
only nine seconds, and lifting weights of
up to five hundred kilos with a single hand.
These entities are not immortal and can be
harmed by conventional means, but that doesn’t
mean it’s an easy task.
Any SCP-1897 instance that is killed or incapacitated
immediately vanishes, resulting in them dropping
anything that they may have been carrying
at the time.
And surprisingly, these are not mindless monsters,
and actually appear to be capable of communication.
Furthermore, they do not seem to speak a unique
or distinct language but instead communicate
in standard American English, with accents
and vernacular appropriate to the regions
they appear in.
However, they will actively refuse to reply
to any human that attempts to engage them
in conversation.
Now, these creatures don’t spend every waking
hour of the day roaming around the states
of Texas, Oklahoma, and all the others we
listed.
If they did, it’s likely a lot more civilians
would have spotted them by now, and would
probably live their lives in fear of these
gigantic five-meter-tall humanoids.
But instances of SCP-1897 will only manifest
if certain specific criteria are met, and
these are as follows.
To encounter SCP-1897, a person must be alone,
or part of a group of no more than two.
If more than one other person is with them,
then no manifestation will occur.
There is one exception to the rule: If a child
under the age of twelve is present.
Secondly, neither the person nor anyone with
them can be carrying any kind of weapon - that
means no knives, no guns, not even pepper
spray.
Third and finally, they must be at least twenty-five
meters from a major population center.
And what happens when all of these conditions
are met and one of these creatures appears?
Anyone witnessing their arrival will notice
the creatures materializing, appearing to
emerge from some form of unseen vehicle.
When they manifest, the SCP-1897 entities
are almost always carrying long poles with
large nets at the end, as well as steel cages,
and are often seen wearing dark green uniforms.
In most cases, they will attempt to capture
any nearby person, in a way that causes them
the least possible harm.
Should an SCP-1897 creature successfully apprehend
a person and place them in a cage, both them
and their captive will vanish in a similar
manner to the way the creature appeared.
All attempts to track SCP-1897 or one of its
abducted victims have failed; there is no
way to know where they are taken.
But as far as what happens to them?
That, we do have a little more insight into.
Sometimes, although it is a highly rare occurrence,
the captured human victims may reappear around
a month after their capture.
While never in the same location as where
they disappeared from, they will always be
accompanied by an SCP-1987 instance and will
stay close by the creature’s side.
At this point, the abductee is barely human
anymore.
They are considered an instance of what is
known as SCP-1897-1.
What signifies this sudden and drastic transformation?
For one, these victims are always found to
have been forcibly castrated or sterilized,
essentially no longer able to reproduce the
way humans naturally do.
For another, these instances of SCP-1897-1
universally display a decreased level of cognitive
and mental function.
What we mean by that is their brains do not
function the way they should anymore.
Instead, these abductees exhibit the same
level of intelligence and capability as the
average Canis lupus familiaris, otherwise
known as the common domestic dog.
Should someone attempt to rescue a person
that has become an instance of SCP-1897-1,
or display hostility towards the SCP-1897
creature that accompanies them, they will
be met with outward, animalistic aggression
from the victim.
It has been discovered by the SCP Foundation
that these behaviors can be treated with amnestics.
Unfortunately, though, the process of an abducted
person becoming an SCP-1897-1 instance seems
to be the result of an invasive medical procedure
known as a lobotomy.
This typically involves removing or disabling
certain parts of the human brain, meaning
that what has been done to these victims is
permanent, and cannot be reversed.
So, who is doing all this?
Why are these creatures collecting innocent
human beings only to reduce them to little
more than animals?
The answers lie in something currently referred
to as SCP-1897-2; not another creature or
entity, not an anomalous artifact or location
with strange properties, but a website found
at the address ‘www.hdsociety.gov’.
According to the information on this site,
it belongs to a group calling themselves the
Human Domestication Society.
The website features pages such as ‘Adoption’,
‘Training’, ‘Breeding Programs’, ‘Volunteering’
and more.
The fact that this is the kind of website
you might expect to be about dogs or cats
but instead focuses on the domestication of
humans is certainly enough to turn the stomach.
As we said at the start of the video, surely
a human being can’t be somebody’s pet,
right?
Wrong, at least as far as the Human Domestication
Society goes.
Their website contains everything and anything
one of these SCP-1897 creatures could ever
hope to learn about owning a human as a pet.
“Has your human been misbehaving?
Need to train them to use the toilet?
These pages have all the information you need
to help your human become the most well-trained
human on your block!”
boasts the Training
page of www.hdsociety.gov.
The remainder of the page contains links to
various articles such as ‘Obedience Training’,
which claims an owner of a human can “show
them who’s boss without the need for physical
violence”.
Also featured are mentions of how to toilet
train or play fetch with a human, how to introduce
a human to others due to them naturally not
getting along.
Perhaps most chilling of all is one article
titled ‘Understanding What Your Human Wants’
that warns human beings shouldn’t talk.
And another, ‘Dealing with Strays’ offers
tips for anyone wanting to capture their own
pets themselves.
It doesn’t seem like too much of a leap
to think that the SCP-1897 creatures have
followed a lot of advice from this particular
article.
Arguably worst of all is an image featured
on the website, of a tall, menacing SCP-1897
entity, brandishing a picana electrical.
This device, for any unfamiliar with that
term, is a form of high voltage electrical
cattle prod, normally used for purposes of
torture.
In the photograph in question, the creature
is wielding one of these while standing sternly
over a helpless captive human male, now an
instance of SCP-1897-1 with tears in his eyes.
Further pages found on www.hdsociety.gov recommend
solutions to certain human behaviors.
For example, like one might expect to find
on other pet care websites, some of the Human
Domestication Society’s articles pertain
to dealing with aggression, grooming, house
training, and even toilet training.
Then there’s the Adoption page, which states
“We offer a large variety of humans for
adoption every single day.
While we cannot guarantee a human you see
listed on our website will be available when
you reach the shelter, our inventory is updated
every half-hour.
We cannot answer any questions about specific
humans pictured on our website over the phone
or email.”
It is still unclear whether or not the SCP-1897
creatures that have been known to appear in
the southwestern United States are sent out
to gather humans en masse to offer for adoption,
or whether these creatures are individuals
trying to obtain human pets on their own.
Of course, the worst conceivable answer is
both.
The site is horrifyingly comprehensive, with
links to an annual human ownership convention
- with panels on breeding and preventing illegal
human poaching and skinning.
It’s safe to say that if ever you were unlucky
enough to read this website, it’d haunt
you for life.
Naturally, the SCP Foundation has made several
attempts to contact the owners of this website.
They tried in vain to communicate through
the official channels about SCP-1897-1 adoption
as a way of peacefully negotiating that the
Human Domestication Society website be shut
down as well as its practices of capturing,
lobotomizing, breeding, and adopting humans.
However, these communication attempts were
met with silence.
That is until a message was received by The
Foundation at Site 06, addressed to a member
of personnel that does not exist.
No data pertaining to the physical location
of the sender could be derived from the email,
but it was traced to the same IP address as
the Human Domestication Society’s website.
The email read as follows: “We will not
listen to your lies any longer.
It was you who came after us first.
You who tore holes in our world and tried
to annihilate us.
You who took our olive branch of peace and
fashioned it into a spear.
You who nearly drove us to extinction.
And now that we have the advantage, you attempt
to patronize us with your crocodile tears.
We will not be deceived again.
“But unlike you, we are not monsters.
We have much anger towards your kind, but
we are willing to forgive.
But first, you must be willing to change.
Slavery and genocide are immoral, and not
even you deserve such a fate.
It is our belief, then, that this alternative
is a fair compromise between guaranteeing
our safety and allowing your kind to live.
This is our mercy to you.
“Look at the humans who have gone through
our program.
See how much happier they are?
Your correspondence tells us that you have
seen them.
Seen how much they love us.
Why, then, do you continue to be defiant?
Someday you will thank us.
Please try to understand that this is for
your own good.”
For now, there is little that the SCP Foundation
can do to prevent the Human Domestication
Society from abducting human beings to sell
as pets to other SCP-1897 creatures.
Civilian access to the hdsociety.gov website
has been restricted, so we recommend you stop
typing into the search bar of your browser
to go take a peek.
Yes, we mean you!
Seriously, stop that!
As for the entities that have appeared in
the rural areas of the southwestern states?
All the Foundation can do is position its
agents nearby, in the hopes that they can
detain and neutralize the SCP-1897s as they
appear, with lethal force if necessary.
At present, the only procedure for any human
pets that are successfully recaptured is to
have them moved safely to containment until
a way of rehabilitating them is found.
So far, there hasn’t been any luck on that
front.
Working at the SCP Foundation can really get
your appetite going.
After spending a rough shift monitoring the
acid levels in SCP-682’s tank, or performing
the rituals necessary to keep the Devourer
of Worlds on the other side of SCP-2317, sometimes
you just need a quick snack to hold you over
before you return to the old grind.
Problem is, at the SCP Foundation, even the
break room can be perilous.
Dr. Dan is notorious for pilfering pudding
cups from the communal fridge, and ever since
The Administrator himself stole your tuna
sandwich, you just don’t feel safe spending
your lunch break on-site anymore.
But this presents its own series of issues:
You only have an hour for lunch, and obviously
you can’t order in due to security issues.
Also, if you’re eating off-site, you have
even less time to finish your lunch, because
the site you’re currently stationed at is
relatively remote.
We’re talking at least a half-hour round-trip
to actually get to somewhere, so you’re
gonna need your food fast.
And when it comes to fast food, few eateries
are as prolific as the Golden Arches: McDonalds.
And just to clarify, this video is not sponsored.
We’re going to tell you about a horrifying
anomalous secret that this company really
doesn’t want you to know about.
Let’s not think about that just yet, though.
Your stomach is rumbling, and you need that
quarter pounder so bad that even being trapped
in the Red Reality with Dr. Scranton couldn’t
stop you from getting it.
When you finally arrive, you buy your typical
order: A quarter pounder with french fries,
a coffee, and a McFlurry.
You see Dr. Clef a few tables down eating
a box of chicken nuggets and ketchup, but
decide not to engage.
As you sit and enjoy your meager little lunch,
knowing you’ll probably be coordinating
the cleaning efforts of SCP-173’s containment
chamber by the end of the day, your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling: Happy,
the current mascot for McDonalds Happy Meals.
You can’t help but shudder.
You’ve seen some pretty horrifying things
on the job.
Nightmarish things.
You fear no monster, but that thing?
It scares you.
Those big, soulless eyes.
The wide, gaping maw full of too-white teeth.
Its diabolical sneakers.
No child should ever have to look at that.
You can’t help but wonder, whatever happened
to Ronald McDonald, the hamburger happy clown
that’d shilled fast food to you throughout
your childhood?
What was he up to now?
Well, we have the answer for you, but I’ll
warn you: You may not be quite as eager to
suck down a Big Mac and diet coke after hearing
this.
Ronald McDonald, first introduced as the company
mascot in 1963, had a pretty good run before
finally being largely phased out by the company
in the mid-2010s for a greater focus on the
nasty little box homunculus.
You can thank John Wayne Gacy, Pennywise,
and those goofballs dressing up as clowns
back in 2016 for that.
But like anyone who loses favor stateside,
Ronald had a prosperous career ahead of him
outside of the country.
Well, not the Ronald we know, at least.
You see, in an undisclosed cattle farm in
2004, most likely in North America, a monster
was born.
A horrific abomination, birthed from a cow,
like many have theorized about SCP-058, the
Heart of Darkness.
But this nasty little creature wasn’t a
giant heart with a stinger and scorpion legs.
In many ways, it appeared superficially humanoid,
save for its stark white skin, its thick red
lips, and its full head of bright, frizzy
red hair.
But that was only the start of the unnerving
strangeness exhibited by this miracle child.
It was born with white gloves and long, clownish
shoes seemingly grafted to its feet.
Fresh from birth, the creature was huge, with
a disproportionately large head and wide,
disgusting pores that seemed to perpetually
leak fry oil.
The creature was unresponsive to any kind
of external stimuli, perhaps suggesting it
was braindead, and it remained completely
dormant most of the time.
While most people would have screamed, run
away, or called the police, the farmers at
this particular cattle farm decided to let
it ride, and see how this whole nightmarish
affair played out.
That sense of curiosity and patience would
soon pay off for them financially.
It didn’t take long for the creature to
grow.
The bigger it got, the more it looked like
a giant, mutant version of McDonalds’ iconic
mascot, Ronald McDonald.
And this wasn’t just a coincidence, either.
It turned out that this monster was somehow
intrinsically linked to the McDonalds brand,
because once a day, the creature would horrifically
unhinge its jaw, and begin to barf out a huge
quantity of McDonalds food.
And we’re not talking about raw materials
that are then converted into McDonalds food.
The creature, later dubbed SCP-5962, vomited
out fully-packaged McDonalds products.
The owners of this clownish monster had just
hit the lottery - so to speak.
While the particulars of the deal are unclear,
they somehow contacted a representative of
the McDonalds corporation based in China.
In exchange for presumably a large sum of
money, Chinese McDonalds operatives covertly
entered the country and shepherded the now-massive
creature over to a McDonalds-owned warehouse
in Beijing.
By this point, it was around four meters tall
and weighed over five tons.
It was kept inside a cage and housed at some
cost, but soon enough, the creature was paying
for itself.
As we mentioned before, the creature constantly
secreted fry oil, which was siphoned off for
use in preparing McDonalds food across the
country.
The huge quantity of packaged food that it
vomited out every day was also shipped off
to restaurants across the country, making
the Chinese branch of McDonalds incredibly
financially successful.
They were able to make an almost complete
profit on all of these foods and drinks, once
transport costs were subtracted, of course.
SCP-5962 had become McDonalds China’s best-kept
secret, but of course, no secret this sensational
could stay under wraps forever.
No matter how much people in the warehouse
were paid or threatened for their silence,
if your day job was siphoning grease off of
a giant mutant clown for the purpose of preparing
McDonalds food across the country, there’d
be no way that you wouldn’t speak to somebody
about it.
Nobody knows whose loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship, but rumors began to spread
around Beijing about a huge clown inside of
a McDonalds packaging facility.
That was when local field agents of the SCP
Foundation finally took notice.
Two agents, Johnathan Zhang and George Nagasu,
were dispatched to perform an infiltration
mission along with a team of backup personnel.
They entered the warehouse, apprehending any
employees they found.
As they and their reinforcements reached the
Northern side of the facility, they found
SCP-5962 with a heavy collar around its neck,
chained to the ground like King Kong, as McDonalds
employees wheeled away carts of packaged food.
Neither of the attending agents were fans
of McDonalds food, but even then, just seeing
this horrible display was enough to make them
feel nauseous.
The creature was taken and contained by the
SCP Foundation, who conducted a number of
tests on it.
They found that the monster had no real internal
organs save for 27 interconnected stomachs.
Genetically, they also found that the creature
was far more cow than human.
The same could sadly not be said for the food
that SCP-5962 was vomiting out.
Seriously, if you were already feeling a little
queasy from all this, we need to warn you
that this is the part where things get really
vile.
Let’s talk about what the McDonalds food
barfed up by SCP-5962 was actually made out
of.
As we alluded to earlier, the food exuded
by the creature was genetically human, with
DNA often matching that of people who are
alive and in no way affected by this anomalous
process.
Tests have indicated that certain foods, condiments,
and beverages correspond to more specific
types of bodily tissue and liquid.
For example, the bacon and fries were shown
to be cartilage and ligaments.
The bread turned out to be made from hair,
nails, and skin.
The coffee was liquified fecal matter.
The chicken nuggets were made from fingers,
ovaries, and testes.
Even the water was a mix of saline and sweat,
and of course, the ice cream was comprised
of pus, bone marrow, feces, and nasal mucus,
depending on the flavor.
You get the idea.
We’ll stop listing off examples before you
lose your lunch, but rest assured, all the
food produced by SCP-5962 was made of human
organic matter.
When the SCP Foundation interviewed Mr. Chen,
the manager of the facility where SCP-5962
was being held, before his amnestic treatment,
he seemed incredibly casual about the whole
thing.
As far as he was concerned, the food still
tasted exactly the same as regular McDonalds
food, and it didn’t appear to have any adverse
health effects beyond what you could expect
from regular, non-anomalous fast food.
It’s actually less cruel and disturbing
than the slaughterhouses where this meat is
typically obtained.
Mr. Chen also contested that SCP-5962 wasn’t
at all dangerous, either: The only time it
ever performed a defensive action was when
an employee of the enemy fast-food franchise,
Burger King, entered its vicinity.
The creature vomited a stream of hot coffee
at the corporate interloper like a firehouse
until he left, suggesting that it does have
some kind of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonalds company.
But still, other than this isolated incident,
the creature had never even displayed sentience.
It was a big, strange, clownish McDonalds
food dispenser.
When questioned about the origins of SCP-5962,
Mr. Chen once again underplayed the strangeness
of the situation, saying that he’d heard
rumors the farm that sold him SCP-5962 had
also sold other strange, anomalous creatures
to eager buyers in the US.
The farm - which we can only assume is situated
right next to a radioactive waste dump - was
also behind SCP-4158, also known as Big Charlie.
This giant, omnivorous, and seemingly immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been birthed
from a non-anomalous cow sold to the Butchers
Block Slaughterhouse.
It looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues, leading to
the employees at the slaughterhouse trying
to put the creature out of its misery.
However, no matter how hard they tried to
kill the monster, it just wouldn’t die.
Its bones were pretty much indestructible,
and no matter how much of its flesh was cut
off, it just kept growing back, causing no
ill effects to the creature itself.
Eventually, the slaughterhouse workers tried
cooking and eating the meat, leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as non-anomalous
meat.
Much like the Chinese McDonalds and SCP-5962,
the workers had just hit the lottery with
Big Charlie.
As long as they kept feeding the monster,
which ate everything from bricks to other,
non-anomalous cows, it provided a pretty much
limitless supply of meat, giving them unprecedented
economic prosperity.
In other words, Big Charlie was a literal
cash cow.
Jeff Fine, the slaughterhouse director, even
started worshipping Big Charlie as a kind
of demi-god by drinking his blood.
He believed that Big Charlie was a savior,
sent to lift them all out of their struggle
and desperation.
Sadly for them, the SCP Foundation sent them
right back when Big Charlie escaped their
slaughterhouse, and Foundation field agents
found, secured, and contained it.
It was a sad day for the Butchers Block.
So, what have we learned today?
Whether you’re in the US of A or the Chinese
heartland, if you’re chowing down on fast
food, you really have no idea where it came
from.
I mean, we kind of knew that already, but
for all we know, the food you’re enjoying
could have been vomited up by a giant fat
clown, or cut from the flesh of a mutated
cow.
Just think about that next time you’re enjoying
a burger.
But hey, let’s be honest with ourselves,
we’ll all probably still eat it.
Whether these are five-star luxury suites
or seedy roach motels, there’s something
undeniably a little eerie about hotels.
They’re liminal spaces - transitional spots
between origins and destinations.
We’ve seen countless creepy hotel rooms
in the horror genre, from Room 237 in The
Shining’s Overlook Hotel to the infamous
Room 1408.
But have you ever heard of Room 710?
Also known by a different number: SCP-2432.
This hotel room is one of the most terrifying
out there, but the funny thing is, you won’t
ever hear a bad word said about it.
Room 710 has glowing - if a little strangely-worded
- reviews across the board.
And when you see how people rave about it
online, you’ll find yourself unable to resist
paying it a visit.
But don’t be nervous.
All those people can’t be wrong, right?
And after all, it’s just a room.
What kind of harm could a room really do?
Let’s ask Chuck Peele, one of the many victims
of SCP-2432.
He was a traveling businessman, caught in
the rat race of relentless sales pitches and
conferences that felt like they were slowly
but surely sucking out his soul.
His next conference was in State College,
Pennsylvania, and he’d spent the evening
researching different places he could potentially
stay during the trip.
Chuck had been disenchanted with chain hotels
over the years - seeing the exact same setups
again and again, all across the country, only
worsened the feeling that his life was going
nowhere.
That’s why, whenever he was traveling out
of town, he always tried to find an interesting
independent place to hang his hat.
That’s what led him to the [REDACTED] Hotel.
The pictures seemed nice, sure, but what really
caught his eye were the positively fantastic
reviews.
Little note: Certain details have been redacted
to avoid subjecting you, the viewer, to the
memetic effects nested in these reviews.
After all, we wouldn’t want you to develop
a sudden hankering for Room 710, and start
buying your tickets to State College, Pennsylvania.
The first review, found on Trip Advisor, said:
“Another great stay in this fabulous hotel!
The room was perfect, the staff friendly as
always, and of course no better location than
on the plane of many hives.
I have enjoyed a drink at the friendly bar,
this time I added a wonderful escape and the
breakfast was cold and the breakfast was warm.
Another great stay in this fabulous hotel!
The restaurant has lovely ambiance and the
food was over the top alive and kicking woo!
Would stifle again.
My husband eats out often and felt this was
the best one ever.
Another great stay in this fabulous hotel!
One more great item to add to the [REDACTED.]
Stayed July 1999, traveled with three family
members.”
The second review, this time posted on Yelp,
read:
“We sailed on our boat into State College
from outside State College through the night
and the cold and arrived at 8am in State College.
The hotel desk staff allowed us to check in
at 8am in the evening with our sixty four
young boys - this was absolutely AWESOME awesome
customer service!
We cannot thank you enough for allowing us
to check in so early in State College.
Earlier then war.
The rest of the stay was fine - we spent almost
all of our time in the room; mostly just to
sleep.
This location is ultra ultra convenient with
downtown downtown State College and allowed
me to make a midnight run for some of my favorite
State College meat while the family was sleeping
and sleeping and sleeping and sleeeeping in
State College.
Downtown.
[REDACTED] Downtown.”
And the final review, which Chuck Peele found
particularly compelling, read:
“Been coming to this region for fourteen
stone.
What a blast.
Scores of humans wondering the streets and
staffing the hotel.
My husband and my husband and I have walked
drooling path to get here.
Bed in Room 710 was soft and cosy and appreciated
the decor would recommend the bed and specifically
the bed and specifically the bed.
[REDACTED] in the pool and it was lovely,
crisp blue hydrogen and you could see all
of the people relax into a meandering menace.
Towel slightly dirty.
Gym was full of usable equipment, so you could
train not in fear.
And the local wildlife was remarkable.
I visited the town in the past and have never
seen so many puma being feasted on [REDACTED]
and the toucan-men were especially numerous
today.
Arrived July 2019, staying three days months
ten years.”
While these may seem like utter nonsense to
you, to someone reading them without the key
memetic trigger phrases redacted, they create
an irresistible urge to visit the hotel and
stay in Room 710.
It was an urge so primal and powerful that
he couldn’t wait to get going, if only because
he could finally stay in this wonderful hotel
and see what all this fuss was about.
He booked his tickets, and a few days later,
he was at the check-in desk.
Something you need to understand is that Room
710 is extremely subtle in its anomalous methods.
Unlike Room 237 or Room 1408, it won’t attack
the victim with ghosts or mind-warping hallucinations.
Nor will it drive them into acts of horrific
violence against the ones they love, or acts
of self-destruction.
One of the frightening things about Room 710
is that, while you’re actually inside it,
you can have an extremely pleasant stay.
It’s only once you leave that things start
becoming truly terrifying.
But we’ll get to that when we get to it.
Chuck made his way up to the room to take
a shower and take the weight off his feet.
And sure enough, the room seemed positively
luxurious: Two queen-sized beds with fine
linen, a spacious closet, a large flatscreen
television, and a well-appointed bathroom
with a combo shower-bath.
This was heaven.
Sure, it was one more bed than he needed,
but this meant he had a choice of which one
he could sleep on.
Fantastic!
This is the insidious power of SCP-2432.
There’s nothing overt about the harm it
causes at first.
Chuck was more worried about the impending
conference than he was about the fact he was
in the belly of the anomalous beast.
However, the SCP Foundation, through later
analysis of the room, found that the anomalous
elements aren’t entirely ephemeral - there
are certain details about the physical makeup
of the room that causes and amplifies its
effects.
The walls are reinforced with hyper-strong
aramid fibers, and it’s believed that the
very makeup of the room serves to create mind-warping
oscillations that are undetectable to the
conscious mind, but are particularly potent
when the victim is asleep.
Chuck didn’t know it, but every moment he
spent in that room, it was crawling into his
head just that little bit more.
He was already subconsciously composing his
nonsensical memetic review of the place.
As the night drew to a close, Chuck decided
to relax and enjoy some television.
The hotel’s website boasted a wide variety
of channels, after all.
But after switching through a few different
channels, he came to rest at a channel simply
called “roomnews.”
It was simple but soothing: An image of a
sailboat in the middle of a pastoral lake,
while what sounded like cheerful elevator
music played.
Chuck simply sat and enjoyed the relaxing
ambiance for a moment, before the music was
interrupted by a deep, British voice, who
began delivering a strange monologue.
For reasons he couldn’t quite explain, Chuck
felt that this voice was speaking directly
to him.
“Let me describe something to you.
This is a true story.
It really happened to me.
It could have happened to you.
Every day you wake up and you go to your job
and there’s just something off about your
boss, he’s weird and clingy and strange.
Your co-workers are nice enough but they don’t
communicate.
They are quiet and out of it and absorbed
in their own little worlds and you are ignored.
Not because you are ugly or awkward or rude
but because you are there.
And you suspect things about your co-workers.
Despite their habits and the strange things
each of them places on their Twitter pages
they seem to be doing so much better than
you.
How are you falling behind?
And you should love the job.
It’s your passion.
Most would die to be doing a job they are
passionate about.
You really should but you can’t.
Wonder becomes routine and routine becomes
drudgery and it’s day in and day out and
you struggle to maintain your soul.
This is not what should happen.
'Should' is such a tormenting word.
A thinking trap.
Should.
Your life is ruled by shoulds.
You come home in your beat-up old car along
the same boring street in your town.
Everything is along that main drag and you
cannot really go elsewhere.
Everything is overcast and the pedestrians
are idiots and the drivers are too.
You get home and have a million, billion projects
to accomplish.
You should compete in the rat race but you’re
bone tired.
You promise your grandmother you should text
her because she’s going through chemo and
she only just figured out texting because
she’s getting old and having a hard time
adjusting and it’s so painful for her and
you should be there but the job is so demanding.
You have a thousand books you should be reading.
You have a million projects you should complete.
The rent on your tiny apartment is due and
the dishes are piling high and dirty in the
sink.
You barely have enough money for pizza as
you lie in your boxers on your greasy 10-year-old
couch from an IKEA in Fishkill, New York that
closed a year ago.
You remember your mom taking you there as
a kid.
Then she left.
You feel a deep, growing anxiety.
The feeling of watching your life burn around
you as you try and try to succeed for something
great, to make your mark on society but you
cannot bring yourself to do so despite your
convictions.
The dread is horrible.
It’s all crumbling apart.
The parade is passing you by and you are helpless.
Immobile in your state like a great boulder
made of disappointment, regret, depression
and malaise.
There is nothing for you here.
You need to leave this place.
You have a choice.
Get your good clean shirt and your smart pants
and announce you are taking a break.
Don’t even pack, don’t even bring your
phone.
One simple call to the office and get on your
way.
Take that old beat-up car from the garage
underneath your apartment complex, give your
cat the last of his food and some water, and
hit the road.
Leave the town and your ex and the promises
you made and your job and your grandmother
and your responsibilities and worries.
What I recommend to you is simple: Find a
hotel.
Not a motel or something shabby.
A hotel.
Even a chain will do.
Hotels are simply remarkable, aren’t they?
Clean and elegant.
All modernistic and designed to appeal to
the eye.
You don’t need to care about a thing in
the world.
Food is provided, they clean up after you
and you can feel like you have some luxury
for once.
Most even have pools and fitness centers where
you can finally get in shape and pick your
life up.
It’s a chance to step back and regroup.
Take a look at the customers around you.
Travelers, most.
Strange people, interesting people.
People you won’t ever see again.
Travel is so romantic, so mysterious.
My, what stories these people probably have!
And the staff, also all so attentive in their
smart little uniforms.
Don’t listen to the naysayers.
These people all love their jobs.
You know they do.
The room is amazing.
The wallpaper is elegant and the paintings
make you feel at ease.
There are clean towels every day and the bed
is freshly made.
You can escape the oncoming storm outside.
The thunder crashing down on the roof like
ball bearings.
You could live your whole life in this place.
Enjoy the sugary cereals at the breakfast
buffet.
Get a loyalty card and pay no money.
Travel really changes a man.
Relaxes him.
Shapes him up into a better person.
You become a better person by staying in a
hotel.
Strong, social, a proper soldier.
You adapt to the hotel mindset.
Enjoy the soft music and eat that fresh waffle.
Grab a beer in the evening with your fellow
transients from the attached sports bar.
Relax and watch that old showing of that superhero
movie on your TV.
Live here forever.
Enjoy the hotel.
Become the hotel.
Never leave.
Why would you want to leave?
Even when you do walk out those pristine glass
sliding doors, you are empty.
The hotel is in your soul now and you feel
a worse person away from it.
You feel yourself slipping back to that grey
life.
A black hole is in your heart.
Your soul is the hotel.
Your consciousness is the hotel.
You are now one with your accommodations.
You are your accommodations are your life.
Ascend.
Isn’t that lovely?”
As he fell asleep, Chuck found himself nodding.
Yes, yes, that is lovely.
How nice it would be to ascend.
Little did he know, he was receiving a broadcast
from SCP-2432-1, a small, boil-like creature
affixed to the back of the television.
Foundation tests have revealed that this creature
is made from a mix of human, rockfish, and
pig-like DNA.
It only causes strange broadcasts when affixed
to the back of this particular television.
But that’s fine.
Chuck rather enjoyed the show.
It gave him a lot to think about…
He left the hotel a changed man a few days
later, once the conference was finally over,
and gave it a glowing review.
It was not long after he’d returned home
that he began to notice the changes taking
place.
Nothing extreme at first - just gaining some
weight, and then, a little stranger, he began
to develop a purple rash that just wouldn’t
go away.
As the rash worsened, it seemed to take on
almost a floral pattern.
Chuck didn’t mind.
If ever you asked him, he’d just murmur
something about “ascending.”
Then the changes got worse.
A television-shaped protrusion made from bone
began to grow in Chuck’s stomach.
His intestines became rickety porcelain pipes.
His liver turned into a plush, well-fluffed
pillow.
His muscles began to take on a similar quality
to the aramid fibers in the walls of Room
710.
But he still didn’t mind.
As he got bigger and bigger, he didn’t mind.
As his organs and bones transformed into furniture
inside him, he didn’t mind.
He didn’t even mind when his body got so
large that it formed a roughly cube-like shape.
In fact, he couldn’t be happier.
He was just like that room.
That beautiful, wonderful room.
Just like the man on the television said:
He was now one with the accommodation, and
he couldn’t be happier.
He’d never much enjoyed being a human, anyway…
Such is the fate of everyone who stays in
SCP-2432 eventually.
You’ll love the room so much that eventually,
you’ll start emulating it.
Sure, that may seem frightening now, but don’t
worry.
On the other end of the transformation, you’ll
be much more...accommodating.
You’re right in the middle of one of the
hottest summers on record.
The days are filled with bright, scorching
sun and searing heat., and you’ve been laying
around with your air conditioning on full
blast just to try and cool yourself off.
Sadly, it’s not really working, and the
heat is becoming way too much.
But then you remember, there’s this married
couple that lives near you, with no kids,
and they happen to have a swimming pool in
their yard.
Normally they keep to themselves, they’d
never let you use their pool, but they’ve
gone out of town for a few days.
Besides, the heat is killing you, you’re
sure that the neighbors wouldn’t mind if
you just took a quick dip, as long as you
clean up after yourself.
They probably wouldn’t even notice you were
ever there.
Cautiously, you make your way to their house.
It’s an unremarkable place, similar to most
of the other houses in this suburb of New
Mexico.
After checking that there’s nobody else
around, you climb the two-meter high cinder
block wall that stands around the back garden.
As you drop to your feet, sweaty and panting
from the unrelenting summer heat, you see
it: the pool, your salvation.
Water never looked so appealing.
Immediately, you step barefoot across the
sun-scorched tiles and sit on the edge, legs
in the water.
It’s cool and refreshing, perfect for a
day as hot as today.
You’re already changed and wearing your
swim trunks, so it doesn’t take long for
you to paddle out to the middle of the pool,
letting that chilled, clean water cool you
off.
As you’re taking a dip, you notice the pool’s
jets turning on automatically.
It’s a little bit odd, but you shrug it
off.
That couple clearly shelled out for a pool
with a lot of fancy bells and whistles.
But extra features aren’t why you’re here,
you came because if you didn’t, then you
could have melted under all that sunlight.
Floating on the surface of the water, you
relax with your arms behind your head and
close your eyes.
You don’t have time to realize that coming
here was a mistake.
Instead, you start to feel relaxed.
So calm, so tranquil.
You’re one with the water around you now.
It’s almost as though you could just disappear…
So, you do.
The police never find any trace of you, everyone
else simply writes it off as a random disappearance.
There’s not even so much as a scrap of your
body left in the pool, just the clear, clean
water.
Why?
Because the swimming pool you decided to take
a cooling dip in wasn’t an ordinary pool.
It was SCP-242.
But don’t worry, you won’t be the last
to make that costly mistake.
What you didn’t know is that the “married
couple” who live in that house are secretly
a pair of SCP Foundation doctors.
The house isn’t even theirs, the Foundation
procured it after the former owner, a retired
out-of-state landlord, strangely vanished.
He had been struggling to find anyone to rent
the place, so eventually decided to give up
on the property game and move in there himself.
After three days, he was never seen again.
Now, that house has only one rule that must
be followed above all else: do not swim in
the pool.
SCP-242 is, at least to the untrained eye,
just an average swimming pool.
A decent nine meters in length, four and a
half wide, and it holds around 53,000 liters
of sterile pool water.
Like we mentioned before, it’s even got
some nifty features like water jets, a dual
waterfall, and a built-in vacuum unit for
sucking out any impurities.
And we mean any impurities.
You see, SCP-242 does go by another name:
the Self Cleaning Swimming Pool.
And while that might not sound as foreboding
or dramatic as “The Scarlet King” or “The
Wendigo Skull” or “The Horrifying Nasty-Dude
of Ultimate Badness” - okay, we made that
last one up - we can assure you that you don’t
ever want to suffer the fate of taking a swim
in this pool.
There was an incident a while ago, recorded
by the Foundation through a secret hidden
camera.
The house where SCP-242 can be found had been
left vacant for a time, and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage of
the empty swimming pool.
This time it was a couple, a man and a woman
in their early twenties.
They climbed up the back wall, undressed,
and even stole a couple of plastic inflatable
rafts from a shed in the house’s backyard.
The water jets switched themselves on, startling
the girl, but her boyfriend told her not to
worry, the filter to clean the pool was probably
just on an automatic timer, right?
Surely it wouldn’t have been anything to
worry about.
After swimming around together for about twenty
four minutes, the couple both agreed that
the water felt warm, tingly even.
Both of them climbed onto their rafts, eventually
falling asleep while still holding each other’s
hands.
But, almost half an hour after the jets had
started, something caused the two rafts to
burst.
The couple awoke, startled by the loud pop
of the splitting inflatables and being plunged
back into the water.
The pool around them immediately began frothing
violently, deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed in
fear and agony.
Both of them tried to desperately swim to
the edge, hoping to leave the pool and get
to safety.
But unfortunately, that plan didn’t work.
Before they could reach the edge, the man
and the woman were pulled under the surface
of the raging water, their limbs thrashing
as they still tried in vain to escape.
Eventually, they vanished under the crimson,
bloody water.
The frothing slowly began to calm, and the
red in the pool dissipated, once again becoming
clear after forty-eight seconds.
The couple were never seen again, and a cover
story was leaked to the press by the SCP Foundation
two weeks after they went missing.
According to them, the pair had eloped together
somewhere in Mexico.
If only, that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them.
So, this swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties, that much is obvious.
But what exactly are those properties, how
exactly does SCP-242 work?
Is it an interdimensional gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if they
spend too long swimming in it?
Or is the swimming pool itself a sentient,
carnivorous creature that lures humans in
only to devour them?
Maybe the water is teeming with invisible,
flesh-eating piranhas that can strip the meat
from a bone in a matter of seconds.
Well, good guesses all around but actually,
it’s none of these.
It’s unclear what causes the pool’s anomalous
effects, it could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in SCP-242.
Or maybe it’s down to the exact shape and
measurements of the pool itself.
It could even be a combination of both.
But whatever the cause, the result is always
the same.
When any object, substance, or even living
organism is placed in SCP-242, it will be
entirely rewritten on a molecular level.
The genetic and atomic structure will fall
apart, and the subject will be transmuted
into sterile water.
In fact, not just clean water, but water that
remains sterile even when removed from the
pool.
If you took a cup of SCP-242’s water and
mixed something like food coloring into it,
the food coloring would not be absorbed into
the water, instead staying as one non-miscible
bubble.
This process doesn’t happen instantly though,
it can vary depending on how contaminated
or complex the substance placed in SCP-242
is.
For example, water sampled from a nearby river
was sterilized and purified by the pool in
about seven minutes.
A sample of stagnant pond water, riddled with
various diseases and germs, took eleven minutes
longer.
What about fifty thousand liters of coal tar?
Well, that one took a little longer, twelve
long days to be exact, but was still turned
into pure, sterile water.
And as for a living human being?
Maybe ask that couple that took a dip in the
Self Cleaning Pool.
The Foundation is naturally fascinated with
the pool, and after extensive examination,
they have determined that SCP-242 doesn’t
seem to have been intentionally designed for
the specific anomalous function it performs.
The components of SCP-242 beyond the pool
itself; the filter, the vacuum, the pipes,
none of these parts nor anything about the
swimming pool’s design appear to be responsible
for disintegrating matter until only water
remains.
You might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in SCP-242,
the water jets and waterfall features switched
themselves on automatically, before the pair’s
grim demise.
Somehow, these features are able to activate
without the need for electricity, as disconnecting
the pool from a power source will not stop
the jets and waterfall from coming on once
a non-water substance is placed into SCP-242.
The same goes for the pool vacuum, which apparently
cannot be jammed or malfunction.
Even when the bottom of the pool is awash
with viscous liquids like that coal tar, the
vacuum will continue to operate as normal,
scrubbing away at the floor of SCP-242.
The one part of the Self Cleaning Pool that
doesn’t work as you would expect is the
water filtration system.
There is never any water being cycled into
the pool, nor out of it.
As a matter of fact, the pipes connected to
the filtration system have all been removed.
Then again, who needs a filtration system
when your backyard swimming pool can just
spontaneously reduce anything to clean water?
But that raises another frightening thought:
Everything that the pool has ever taken and
converted is still in there - animals, objects,
people - just swimming around you.
Perhaps, if they could still think, they’d
scream and shout and tell you to get away.
To run while you still can.
But the second your skin touches the water,
you’re destined to be with them.
Forever and ever and ever.
It’s enough to send a liquid chill down
your spine.
Okay, so if it’s not the actual physical
pool that causes these anomalous effects,
that must mean it’s something in the water,
right?
Perhaps some microscopic, flesh-devouring
microbe, or some ancient curse that was placed
on the water before it was used to fill the
pool?
Surely, if you took a cup of the water out
of SCP-242, it would still break down structures
on a molecular level, leaving only more sterile
water.
Well, the researchers working at the SCP Foundation
thought much the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact properties
of SCP-242’s water.
One test involved submerging two D Class test
subjects, each wearing an atmospheric dive
suit, into SCP-242.
The goal was to determine if it was safe to
consume the water from SCP-242 while both
inside and outside of the pool.
Test Subject A was lowered into the water
and instructed to drink from a metal straw
by their mouth.
The eyepieces of their goggles were blacked
out, so they couldn’t see what they were
drinking from.
Subject B filled a barrel with the same water
from SCP-242, and then was made to put on
an atmospheric dive suit, but instructed to
stay out of the pool.
Test Subject A was told to drink directly
from the pool, remarking that the water was
warm, and had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste, but was otherwise normal.
Then, Test Subject B drank some of the same
water from the barrel.
Apparently, it was cool, and tasted of…
well, nothing, just like water usually does.
After a moment more of drink, Subject A began
belching, finding they had uncontrollable
gas.
The water had begun to feel warmer, stinging
the subject’s mouth while, for Subject B,
the water from the barrel stayed cool and
refreshing.
The Foundation doctors overseeing the experiment
instructed Test Subject A to keep drinking,
which they did until it felt even hotter to
the taste.
One of the D Class’s fillings even fell
out, and eventually, the structural integrity
of Subject A’s dive suit failed, presumably
disintegrated by the water from SCP-242.
After a few muffled screams and gurgling noises,
Test Subject A wasn’t heard from again,
and we can all probably guess why.
As for Subject B, they kept drinking from
the barrel, suffering no adverse effects,
even after seventeen long hours.
There were no noticeable psychological or
physical changes, even their urine showed
no traces of abnormality.
The water from SCP-242 left in the barrel
evaporated as normal, leaving behind no residue
or any indicator as to why taking the water
out of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool.
Perhaps the moral of the story is to just
be careful where you choose to take a swim,
otherwise, it could be your last.
It was an ordinary night at Site 19 and Dr.
Smith was hard at work in his office.
The overhead light was just about ready to
give out, the bulb dim and flickering, but
there was no one available to change it at
the moment so he would just make do.
Besides, he only had a little bit of work
left to finish.
Hunched over his desk, eyes bleary and head
aching from too many hours of staring at a
screen, he was ready to wrap up this report
and finally get home for some well-deserved
rest.
The constant anxiety of working with some
of the scariest monsters in the world was
one thing, but the hours spent writing paperwork
on the monsters was an altogether different
kind of terrifying.
Most of the research staff had left for the
night, and only Dr. Smith and the usual security
team remained in the building.
There was no sound except the click of his
fingers on the keys, his occasional exhausted
sigh, and the infrequent sound of footsteps
in the hall outside as a security officer
made his rounds.
Dr. Smith leaned back in his chair, stretching
his arms over his head and feeling his back
crack.
Almost done.
He recalled, dimly, a thermos of tea he had
left on the shelf behind him.
Perhaps that would be the kick he needed to
finish this work up and get home to his bath,
his books, and his pet cat Roger.
He swiveled his chair around, preparing to
stand up and retrieve the thermos when he
suddenly came face to face with a nightmare.
There, less than an inch from him, was a smooth
featureless face, black as the night and devoid
of any expression.
It was hunched over, its face peering into
him, despite not having any eyes itself.
Without a sound, without so much as a creak
of the door, this thing had come into his
office and appeared behind him, waiting for
him to turn around and see it.
Dr. Smith let out a shriek of terror, knocking
his chair over as he scrambled to get away
from the intruder.
His heart pounding in his ears, he tore past
the dark figure, yanking open the door to
his office and taking off running down the
hall.
He called out for help, for someone, anyone,
to come.
Several security personnel heard his cries
and rushed to see what had happened.
They found a shivering Dr. Smith, babbling
about a “demon” in his office and repeating
“it doesn’t have a face” over and over
again.
Once he had calmed down - and finally been
given that cup of tea - Dr. Smith was informed
that as stressful as that encounter might
have been, he was never really in any danger.
We don’t have another SCP-173 on our hands
here, thankfully.
This statue isn’t murderous or even violent.
To the best of our observational ability,
we’ve determined that this particular surprisingly
mobile statue is just kind of a jerk.
SCP-650, nicknamed “The Startling Statue,”
is a stylized black statue of a humanoid figure,
standing at 167 centimeters tall.
It has no hands or facial features, its arms
ending in rounded points, and its face and
head a smooth surface like that of a mannequin.
When the statue is dormant, or at least resting
and waiting for its next chance to move, it
stands straight and reaches upwards, head
tilted up as if its nonexistent eyes are watching
the sky.
Attempts to determine the materials the statue
is made of have proved inconclusive.
Some tests show an impossibly large combination
of different materials, where other tests
came back with no matches for any recognized
materials at all.
If no one is observing the statue, it will
move to a place immediately behind whoever
is in the room with it, switching its pose
to a more threatening one.
It moves silently, and no one has been able
to capture evidence of its method of locomotion.
All that is known is that it does in fact
move, and it always appears extremely close
to the subject of its interest, in order to
provoke a strong fight-or-flight reaction.
The statue seems to have no interest in harming
those it frightens, never touching or directly
interacting with anyone.
It only seems interested in startling its
victims, if you can even call them “victims.”
It can be unpleasant to be unexpectedly frightened
like that, sure, but you get the same experience
at most Halloween attractions or horror movies,
and people pay good money for those.
Several trials were conducted in order to
determine the statue’s pattern of behavior.
In each trial, an SCP Foundation agent was
assigned to stand in the statue’s containment
unit and watch the object for a period of
time.
When prompted by a researcher in another room,
speaking to them via radio, they were ordered
to look away from the statue.
Once cleared to look at the statue again,
they were ordered to look around the room
and report where it went, and what it was
doing.
In most of the experiments, the statue appeared
directly behind the personnel, angled with
its arms reaching toward them and its head
glaring down at them, as if about to attack.
In nearly every trial, the statue hit the
same position, and the Agent looking at it
was startled to the point of screaming.
There was even talk of cutting footage of
all of the screams together into a video that
would be shown at the company Christmas party.
However, in three cases, the statue adopted
a different pose as well as position in the
room, much to the surprise and confusion of
the team conducting the experiments.
When Agent Dunne was assigned to observe the
statue, he was asked to close his eyes for
five seconds and wait for SCP-650 to move.
When he opened his eyes, the first thing he
did was whirl around and look behind him,
having heard about the results of the previous
tests.
However, when he turned to face the statue,
there was nothing there.
He turned back around to his original stance,
preparing to radio Command and tell them the
statue was gone, when he let out a yelp of
surprise.
There, at the table in the corner several
feet away, was the statue.
It was lying on the table with its arms behind
its head, as if relaxing, with the area considered
to be its “face” turned directly toward
Dunne.
Unsettled by the surprise, and definitely
uncomfortable with how the statue seemed to
be looking at him, he left the room without
another word.
At another point in the trials, Agent Riley
pulled the short straw and was told to enter
650’s containment.
She stood in the center of the room and stared
at the statue in front of her for a long period
of time.
When given the command, she closed her eyes
and waited for a duration of 30 seconds.
Much like Agent Dunne, her first instinct
on opening her eyes was to turn around and
look behind her, ready to see the statue there.
Instead, however, it was sitting on a chair
at the other end of the room, the points where
its hands should be neatly folded in its lap.
Its body was facing away from Agent Riley,
but even though she was looking at what could
have easily been the back of the statue’s
head, she later reported the distinct sense
that it was looking at her.
Though she didn’t scream like her colleagues
had when it was their turn to watch the statue,
she confessed to feeling an overwhelming sense
of unease, and her hands would not stop shaking
for the next several hours.
These two instances of the statue adopting
a casual posture and keeping its distance
from its observers were bizarre, but the final
break from the statue’s usual behavior was
the strangest of them all.
Agent Cho was sent into SCP-650’s containment
and told to stand with his back against the
wall of his choice.
The plan was to determine what the statue
would do if its usual favorite position, just
behind the observer, was no longer an option.
If there was no space behind Agent Cho, then
the statue could not turn up there.
Once he was settled into his spot and had
been watching the statue for several minutes,
Agent Cho closed his eyes for exactly one
minute.
When he opened them, he immediately scanned
the room to see where the statue had gone.
It was not at the table or the chair, nor
was it standing in its original place in front
of him.
Finally, he spotted it.
The statue was huddled in the corner of the
room, curled up in an approximation of the
fetal position.
Its head was down, and its arms were held
up in front of its face as if trying to protect
itself.
Though he could not explain why, Agent Cho
got a distinct impression that the statue
was afraid.
His stomach dropped at the sight, and he would
later admit to his supervisor that he briefly
thought about trying to comfort SCP-650 somehow.
The impulse passed, but Cho was left with
a mixture of anxiety and guilt as if he had
done something wrong and upset the statue.
The sensation did not pass until he was out
of the room.
It is not entirely clear why the statue chose
these alternative poses during these particular
experiments.
The prevailing theory among the research team
is that these are simply other tools in its
arsenal, methods that it can use to elicit
a strong reaction from a person who is less
likely to be startled by its usual trick.
Following the incident with Dr. Smith, SCP-650
was upgraded from Safe Class to Euclid Class.
Just to clarify, for the people in the back:
Euclid Class SCP’s are not necessarily considered
to be dangerous but require more effort to
contain than objects classified as Safe.
Most SCP’s that display autonomy or independent
thought, but are not overtly hostile toward
humanity, are classified as Euclid.
Along with its updated status, special containment
procedures have been employed in order to
keep this Startling Statue from making any
more surprise escapes.
SCP-650 is to be stored in a locked room,
4 meters by 4 meters.
It is to be kept under constant surveillance
by at least three personnel at any given time,
standing so that the SCP and at least one
of the observers are visible to them at all
times.
They are allowed to watch the statue remotely,
via security camera, as long as they remain
focused on the SCP.
This method is only to be employed in case
of emergency.
A great deal of the Foundation budget was
dedicated to maintaining up-to-date containment
facilities for SCP-650, as demanded in a note
from Dr. Smith.
in the official file for SCP-650.
The note reads: “I don't give a flying rat
about the budget; keep this damn thing contained!
Turning around in a dim office to see this
thing a half-inch away from your nose is guaranteed
to take years from your life.
And given what we deal with, we don't have
many to spare.”
So, what does the Startling Statue want?
Why does it use its power of mobility to scare
people but never do anything beyond that?
No one is certain, and the Foundation has
too many other fires to put out to bother
looking further into a clearly benign entity.
Unfortunately, there are questions about SCP-650
that will never be answered, and there is
so much about it we will never know.
One thing is for sure, though.
If you find yourself alone in a room with
an unsettling statue, you had better keep
an eye on it.
Just in case.
BOO!
Well hello there, boils and ghouls!
We hope we didn’t startle you too hard there,
it’s only us, your good old friends at SCP
Explained.
We all love a little fright now and then,
don’t we?
After all, that would explain our fascination
with the morbid tales of the SCP Foundation.
Rotten old men who can walk through walls,
and tear you limb from limb in their own private
hells?
Nightmarish Sarkic diseases that turn anyone
who touches them into a horrible abomination?
Evil masks that kill you and take over your
body, using it to do acts of great cruelty
until you melt down into black goo?
Oh...You’re not scared of those?
You think you’re so tough, so prepared for
anything, that even those anomalous beings
of pure terror can’t break through the impenetrable
shell of your bravery?
Well...I suppose we better bring out the big
guns, then.
Just remember, when you’re huddled in the
corner, bones rattling in fear, that you brought
this on yourself.
After all, there’s no entity quite as good
at inspiring screams as SCP-2006.
So please stay awhile, and find out why this
one’s called...Too Spooky.
We’re sorry you had to hear that.
But you really can’t blame us for having
a little theatricality with this one - In
fact, having a good grasp of theatricality
is actually essential to everyone dealing
with SCP-2006.
Forget gunplay, rituals, and mind games, SCP-2006
requires Foundation-subsidised acting lessons
in order to work on his containment.
Which, even as Foundation containment methods
go, is pretty darn strange.
When you got into this line of work, you probably
expected you’d be in high-intensity battles
with SCP-682, or attending conferences on
how best to repel the menace of The Scarlet
King - Not acting out scenes from A Streetcar
Named Desire with Dr. Bright.
But believe us, it’s important work.
As they’ll probably tell you at these classes,
“There are no small parts, only small actors.”
You won’t spend time at these sessions perfecting
Shakespearian soliloquies, instead, you’ll
be adopting a much narrower focus: Learning
how to properly act and express fear.
The more convincingly scared you can appear,
the better.
Because when it comes to SCP-2006, your job
and potentially even your life depend on it.
Plus, it’s the only time that peeing your
pants and collapsing on the job may actually
get you a raise, rather than just a series
of strange looks from your co-workers.
When you pass that course with flying colors,
you’re finally ready to actually come face
to face with the Prince of Nightmares himself:
SCP-2006.
By this point, you’ve had it drilled into
your head so many times that you could never
forget it: For the love of God, whatever this
thing does, you act scared.
Don’t stonewall, don’t smile, and whatever
you do, don’t laugh.
Laughing at SCP-2006 is probably the fastest
way you can get demoted to swabbing feces
in SCP-173’s chamber.
If you know what’s good for you, you’ll
dial up that fear.
When the big day comes, you’re sent into
SCP-2006’s airtight containment chamber
with a special package.
That time of the month has come once again
- You need to deliver the goods.
You spot a television in the corner first,
still on but tuned to static.
You’re pondering what a waste of electricity
this is when SCP-2006, who’d been hiding
behind an armchair, decided to finally strike.
You barely had time to realize what was going
on when a large, dark shape suddenly blotted
out your vision.
It was over six feet tall, and it looked...Well,
it looked like a man in an exceedingly cheap
gorilla costume, except with a goofy diving
helmet with what looked like TV antennas on
top.
It waved its arms around wildly, as if to
hammer home the point that, yes, this really
was happening, and you should be terrified
by it.
The creature bellowed, “FEAR ME MORTAL.
I AM THE MIGHTY RO-MAN!
COWER IN FEAAAAAAAR!”
At that moment, your weeks of training kicked
in, almost like a reflex.
You let out an ear-piercing shriek and drop
down to the floor, desperately crawling away
from the goofy-looking creature.
Eyes wide, breathing heavy, movements frantic
and defensive.
You gather yourself up in one of the room’s
corners and curl into a ball, covering your
face.
Imbuing your voice with a well-practiced quiver,
you say, “Please mighty Ro-Man!
Don't h-hurt me!
I have so much to live for, just please, let
me go!”
The monster holds a, quote-unquote, “menacing”
pose for a few seconds longer, before slackening
into a joyful laugh.
It even extended a rubbery gorilla paw to
help you up.
Of course, you hesitate for a few seconds,
gazing fearfully, waiting for it to say.
“Ha ha ha!
It's just me, doc!
I got you pretty good, didn't I?”
And as far as he knows, yes, he did.
You’re sure to never slip into the body
language of comfort.
It’s utterly vital that SCP-2006 truly believes
that he’s scary to you, even though he looks
like a terrible monster costume from an even
worse low-budget B-Movie.
Though specifically, the Ro-Man, the monster
from the 1953 trash classic, “Robot Monster.”
You tell SCP-2006 that you’re here with
some more stimulus material for him, and hand
him a plastic bag.
When he asks you what you’ve brought him
this time, you tell him you can’t even look
at it.
If you so much as laid eyes on it, you’d
slip into a terrified state of catatonia.
You’d honestly rather look at 096 than look
at what you’ve brought him today.
SCP-2006 cocked his head to the side, and
asked, “What’s 096?”
Oh no.
The terror that was fake before wasn’t quite
so fake now.
You’d slipped up, buddy, and if you didn’t
come up with a good save quickly, you would
be in deep trouble.
You gulp and take a quick breath, trying to
compose yourself, before saying that 096 is
just another movie.
One that’s not nearly as scary as the one
you’ve prepared for him.
That seemed to satisfy him, so you internally
breathe a sigh of relief, and turn to make
your exit.
You’ve just left SCP-2006 with a DVD copy
of the 1977 “classic”, Death Bed: The
Bed That Eats.
A somewhat obscure horror movie about an evil
bed created by a demon.
That should tide the eccentric anomaly over
for another month.
So, you’re probably wondering: What actually
just happened?
What’s the logic?
What are the connections between the strange
sequence of events we all just witnessed?
While it may seem bizarre now, once you know
more about SCP-2006, it’ll all make sense.
We can’t promise it’ll actually seem any
less bizarre by the end, though.
SCP-2006 is a Keter-class shapeshifting anomaly.
Its default form is a floating sphere of about
fifty centimeters in diameter.
Not exactly terrifying - And this is actually
a big problem for SCP-2006, as the mischievous
anomaly has an almost compulsive desire to
scare people.
Not to physically harm them in any way, just
give them a good, old-fashioned spook.
He’s shown to be pretty much indestructible,
so neutralization is off the table.
You may be thinking, “He seems like a pretty
harmless goofball, why would anyone want to
neutralize him?”
And...Well, we’ll answer that one later.
Back to SCP-2006’s favorite hobby: Scaring
people.
While 2006 seems to practically live off of
giving a good scare, he’s thankfully no
Pennywise.
2006 has no inherent knowledge of what scares
humans, and thus, has to learn what scares
humans from external sources.
This unique weakness to SCP-2006’s ability
is one the Foundation has discovered an ingenious
method of exploiting for its containment:
They simply keep SCP-2006 misinformed on what
people actually find scary, tricking it to
make sure that it’s always hopelessly inept
at its hobby.
Their method of achieving this is twofold.
Firstly, they give SCP-2006 a monthly supply
of the worst horror movies you can imagine.
True bargain bucket B-movie schlock: Troll
2, Leprechaun: In The Hood, Birdemic: Shock
& Terror, The Gingerdead Man, The Beast of
Yucca Flats, Plan 9 From Outer Space, The
Creeping Terror, The Man Without a Body, Manos:
The Hands of Fate, Track of the Moon Beast,
and of course, the seminal classic, Eegah
- A movie about an evil caveman being unfrozen
and terrorizing Palm Springs.
Movies like this are a perfect mechanism for
tricking SCP-2006, because it sees the characters
in the movies reacting with fear to the terrible,
hokey monsters rampaging across backlots and
soundstages, and starts to believe that these
B-Movie beasts are actually scary.
That’s the first part of the trick, and
you’ve probably already figured out the
second half: The Foundation makes sure that
any employees who interact with SCP-2006 in
any capacity must play the part of appearing
actually, genuinely frightened by it.
This one-two punch of trickery keeps SCP-2006
successfully bamboozled.
As such, despite being a creature largely
based around creating fear - albeit, in a
more friendly, playful way than most anomalies
- it’s seen as a joke among staff members.
It wouldn’t be surprising to hear that different
staff members took turns laughing at surveillance
footage.
Or that at the latest Site Halloween Party,
a few drunken researchers tried to trick SCP-2006
into assuming the form of David S. Pumpkins
from Saturday Night Live.
As you could probably gather, developing such
an unimpressed attitude to containing anomalies
with the SCP Foundation is never a good thing.
After all, even some of the most innocent-looking
ones can hide surprisingly dark secrets.
Dr. Randall Owings, the Site Director for
Site 118 - where SCP-2006 is held - released
a stern memorandum to everyone working in
2006’s proximity.
It read:
“I have been getting reports of some of
the lax behavior regarding SCP-2006.
Many personnel have been heard laughing at
SCP-2006 during surveillance when it watches
a new movie, or when it attempts to scare
individuals.
Some personnel have been heard questioning
why SCP-2006 is classified as a Keter entity.
I am here to remind you that a Keter entity
is a Keter entity, regardless of how innocuous
it may seem.
No, SCP-2006 is not a rampaging demi-god,
nor is it a regenerating super lizard.
However, it possesses the same level of danger
as any other Keter that the Foundation has
contained.
Think of SCP-2006's purpose.
It wishes to scare people.
Imagine what would happen if SCP-2006 broke
containment, and found out what really scared
people.
Imagine if it saw the horror and fear of war,
or the concepts of paranoia or phobias common
to each and every human being.
Imagine if it found the true horror of a nuclear
holocaust or an XK-Class scenario.
Now couple that with an entity that possesses
shape-shifting abilities with no known limits,
and you'll understand why it's classified
as Keter.
All personnel mentioned above have been suitably
disciplined.
I do not want to hear about this again.”
SCP-2006 is only as harmless as the Foundation’s
containment procedures allow it to be.
It’s why it can never know about other anomalies
or any actually frightening works of fiction.
If ever SCP-2006 became aware of the true
sources of human fear, there would be no stopping
it, seeing as the creature appears to be indestructible.
Like many of the anomalies kept under lock
and key by the SCP Foundation, it’s a ticking
time bomb that one little mistake could turn
into an utter catastrophe.
Terrible movies and theatrical staff members
need to keep SCP-2006 in the dark about what
actually scares us, because, beyond that,
the only limit to the danger of SCP-2006 is
the human imagination.
And that, my friends, is a very spooky thought
indeed.
An SCP Foundation researcher sits at a table
inside of a standard containment cell.
These are often dangerous places to be, especially
when the SCP you’re supposed to be studying
is one that you can’t see.
The researcher is taking notes, unsure of
exactly what’s going to happen next.
He can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind, of flesh sizzling and searing from
high heat.
He braces himself as a burst of heat hits
the back of his head, as if a fireball has
erupted.
Just then it happens - an object floats through
the air and settles in front of him on the
table.
It’s a plate of food, and it looks delicious.
It may surprise you to learn that there is
no rule that the SCP Foundation must deal
exclusively with violent and vicious creatures.
Not every SCP held in containment shares the
same malevolence and contempt for humanity
as SCP-682, or the world-ending threat posed
by the likes of SCP-2317.
Some - perhaps not many, but some - are benign
and might even seem outwardly friendly, but
you’d still be taking a huge risk to assume
that anything contained by the SCP Foundation
is completely harmless.
Such is the case with SCP-5031.
As per the Foundation’s containment procedures,
this quasi-humanoid – meaning it appears
to have some vaguely human features - is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation personnel on a bi-weekly basis.
SCP-5031 has no need for regular nutrition
or regular interactions from staff.
The trick with SCP-5031, is not being eaten
by it, since though it doesn’t need food,
it does still hunt and consume anything it
encounters - human or otherwise.
Avoiding being eaten is hard enough with creatures
that can actually be seen, but like so many
other creatures the Foundation keeps contained,
SCP-5031 has developed an almost-perfect defense
mechanism - which is that when observed, it
will literally cease to exist.
Some might choose to refer to this as a ‘quantum
lock’, however it is worth noting that traces
left by SCP-5031 still remain observable when
the creature has temporarily disappeared.
For example, trails of blood and scratch marks
left behind by SCP-5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does not.
Naturally, this makes both avoiding the creature
and capturing it using cameras difficult.
However, when SCP-5031’s existence ceases
it still casts a shadow.
From this, researchers have been able to determine
several of the creature’s physical traits.
Based on its silhouette, it has been deduced
that SCP-5031 levitates about half a meter
above ground level, it sports an abnormally
small, neckless head atop an elongated torso
- approximately 1.9 meters long - with three
sets of spindly lower arms that branch outwards.
Using these arms and its loosely hanging body,
SCP-5031 will lower itself to hunt any human
or animal that draws near to it and uses the
bladelike tail to cut up food.
Perhaps the most interesting facet of SCP-5031
beyond its defensive capabilities and apparent
physical attributes, are the series of nine
tests conducted by Senior Researcher Stanley
Huxtable.
Appalled by the conditions that the creature
was being kept in, Huxtable took over the
role of HCL Supervisor for SCP-5031.
Having grown increasingly frustrated and empathetic
towards the creature, listening to its screams
from inside its iron containment unit, Huxtable
devised a series of tests to introduce SCP-5031
to various different stimuli as a way to better
understand the creature and hopefully keep
it contained in a way that didn’t seem to
cause so much suffering.
It's worth remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes it its mission to be cold, not cruel,
in performing their duties to protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff are
just as capable of having empathy for creatures
as you might for a stray animal at a shelter.
The first of Huxtable’s tests involved installing
speakers in SCP-5031’s cell, through which
a variety of different ambient and popular
pieces of music were played to see if they
had any effect on reducing the creature’s
stress.
By judging SCP-5031’s stress levels based
on how much it screamed when compared to normal,
Huxtable was able to determine how to best
to use music to calm the creature.
SCP-5031 seemed to convey higher levels of
stress when listening to ‘Morning Forest’,
‘Deep Grotto’ and ‘Seaside Paradise’
ambience, as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull.
However, the best of Mozart, Enya, KISS and
Ben Folds produced dramatically different
results, decreasing SCP-5031’s apparent
stress.
Following this test, Senior Researcher Huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring SCP-5031’s
favorite music.
Over time, the stress-reducing effects of
music on SCP-5031 seemed to decrease, but
keeping the playlist on shuffle seemed to
keep the creature consistently calmer than
it had been previously.
The next test involved introducing inanimate
objects into SCP-5031’s enclosure to monitor
its reactions and how its stress levels were
affected.
When a softball was thrown into the enclosure,
SCP-5031 immediately sliced the ball in two
with its tail in one swift motion.
A similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature a basketball, which was
quickly punctured and sliced open by SCP-5031’s
tail.
Its stress levels first seemed to diminish
when the creature was offered a bowling ball,
which it rolled around the enclosure and then
later knocked against a second bowling ball.
However, when one of the balls chipped, rendering
it unable to roll properly, SCP-5031’s stress
increased dramatically, until a replacement
was offered.
Researcher Huxtable noted that SCP-5031 seemed
to possess a similar level of motor skills
to an average human toddler, with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to match.
Next, when given the choice between two food
sources at opposite ends of its enclosure,
SCP-5031 seemed to gravitate towards higher-quality
food, most notably favoring cooked rotisserie
chickens over animal carcasses.
It even chose this option over a live chicken,
using its tail to cut its food into more manageable
bite-sized portions, rather than ripping its
meat with its hands or teeth like many of
its fellow SCPs.
Researcher Huxtable recorded these findings
and highlighted that, even though SCP-5031
didn’t need to eat in order to survive,
providing the creature with food of a better
quality marginally reduced its stress.
Senior Researcher Huxtable next attempted
to test SCP-5031’s coexistence with other
living subjects, each time making sure that
the creature had been adequately fed to avoid
any unseemly incidents.
First, a live chicken was introduced.
SCP-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high speed
towards the chicken, increasing both its and
the chicken’s stress levels, and inadvertently
killing the chicken in the process.
When a second chicken was introduced, SCP-5031
gently rolled a basketball towards it but
ceased any further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball.
Next to be introduced into the enclosure was
a blindfolded D Class staff member, who was
instructed to sit down and roll the basketball
towards SCP-5031.
After doing so for several minutes, the creature
began to approach the D class subject, who
was instructed to remove their blindfold to
cease the creature’s existence and prevent
any potentially deadly incidents.
Finally, Researcher Huxtable had another Class-D
engage in a game of catch with SCP-5031 while
facing away from the creature.
This test proceeded successfully, and Senior
Researcher Huxtable remarked how SCP-5031’s
motor skills were improving.
Albeit gradually, and with some gentle encouragement,
through Huxtable’s tests the creature was
learning.
The next test, focused on teaching SCP-5031
linguistic symbols, utilized LCD displays
and buttons connected to a food dispenser.
One display showed an image of a rock, and
the other an image of a rotisserie chicken.
After some brief probing, SCP-5031 was quickly
able to understand that pressing the button
under the correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat.
The creature was later able to adapt when,
the following day, the screen displays and
materials dispensed were swapped, and then
later set to swap at random intervals.
When additional rock-dispensing stations were
introduced, this time displaying the word
‘rock’ as opposed to an image, SCP-5031
was able to determine which station dispensed
‘chicken’ through a process of elimination.
Whenever the functions and displays were swapped,
SCP-5031 would find whichever displayed the
word ‘chicken’ to receive its food.
The final phase of this test presented SCP-5031
with a single station, displaying the word
‘chicken’, but with a button that would
remain inactive unless the creature spelled
out the same word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with.
After some initial confusion and frustration
as to why the button would not dispense food
when pressed, SCP-5031 was able to assemble
the word correctly, not only activating the
button and dispensing food, but proving to
Researcher Huxtable that the creature was
capable of learning language.
Huxtable continued to test the creature, encouraging
it to spell words using lettered blocks as
a method of communicating.
By increasing SCP-5031’s vocabulary and
the amount of human interaction it received,
Senior Researcher Huxtable observed that SCP-5031
was gradually learning to sing - albeit nonverbally
- as well as to juggle with its six hands
and was even communicating its own food preferences
and dish pairings.
Later, another Class-D, D-52125, was introduced
to SCP-5031’s enclosure to aid in further
testing.
Through D-52125’s instructions, the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons, and
created artworks depicting itself, its newfound
friend D-52125, Researcher Huxtable, a cat
and a rotisserie chicken.
SCP-5031’s new creative side didn’t stop
there though, as the creature quickly learned
to play Chopsticks in only two days once a
piano was introduced into the enclosure.
SCP-5031 even managed to start creating its
own original, admittedly crude, compositions.
Next, a spice rack was placed inside the creature’s
cell and D-52125 demonstrated how to season
meat.
This proved to be SCP-5031’s new favorite
hobby, as it spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and spices,
using its letter blocks to request ‘more,
more, more’ garlic powder.
Interestingly, the creature only created artwork
or music when D-52125 was present, but seemed
to thoroughly enjoy its experimentation with
food when left alone.
Following this development, Senior Researcher
Huxtable devised a new test for SCP-5031.
Providing the creature with cooking utensils
and using D-52125 to demonstrate, 5031 was
shown how to prepare a variety of different
dishes, from hamburgers and tacos, to Mongolian
Beef, steak, clam chowder and profiteroles.
In addition to a small peanut allergy, this
eighth test revealed SCP-5031 to be a phenomenal
chef, possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person.
The creature quickly and enthusiastically
embraced its newfound talents, concocting
its very own brand-new recipes, with D-52125
even volunteering to be the first to taste
test 5031’s dishes.
It was shortly after this test that SCP-5031
spoke its very first word, and it should come
as no surprise that the word was ‘salt’.
Naturally, Senior Researcher Huxtable was
very proud of the progress the creature had
made with its development.
The final test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for.
Over the course of two months, SCP-5031 was
tasked with creating a full three-course meal
which would then be served to Foundation staff
for Thanksgiving.
SCP-5031 not only rose to the task, but exceeded
all of Researcher Huxtable’s expectations,
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramsey would
be hard pressed to find fault with.
The creature created a first course consisting
of sweet potato miso soup seasoned with turmeric.
Next came a beautiful duck confit, glazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compote, paired with
a side of butternut squash gnocchi and served
on a bed of kale seasoned with truffle salt.
The grand finale of the exquisite meal was
a spiced cassava pie for dessert, complemented
with the finest French vanilla ice cream and
a maple-hazelnut syrup.
And SCP-5031 didn’t stop there, the creature
also debuted one of its original musical compositions
to compliment the decadent meal it had created.
As the staff enjoyed the food, SCP-5031 performed
live from its enclosure the deeply moving
Piano Concerto for Six Hands, to an overwhelmingly
positive response from not only Senior Researcher
Huxtable, but the entire Foundation staff.
As a fitting end to the creature’s tale,
Huxtable reported that, during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created, SCP-5031’s stress
levels reduced entirely.
New kinder containment measures that would
keep 5031 safer but also far more contented
were submitted for approval.
Perhaps some of you may find it refreshing
to learn that SCP-5031 isn’t simply just
another malicious, malevolent monster that
the Foundation has to keep under lock and
key for the safety of the world.
Instead, SCP-5031 is a gentle – if a little
frightening at first creature - that just
requires careful and considered guidance instead
of a cold iron cage and around-the-clock armed
guards.
Through testing, Senior Researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff were
not only able to help the creature develop,
but also found what makes it tick; and not
just for the purposes of containing it.
Instead, it is hoped that SCP-5031’s creativity
and flair for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow, under the
proud watch of Researcher Huxtable.
Now for something from the more terrifying
archives of the SCP Foundation Check out “SCP
– 096 - The Shy Guy” or “SCP-106 - The
Old Man”